bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur Public Sénat cet après-midi les
sénateurs poursuivent l'examen en séance
publique du projet de loi sur la réforme
de la décentralisation il continue de
réécrire intégralement le texte présenté
et proposé par la ministre Marie-Lise
Lebranchu vendredi soir ils ont
supprimer deux mesures phares de ce
texte à savoir la création d'une
conférence territoriale pour l'action
publique à sorti d'un pacte de
gouvernance territoriale alors cet
après-midi les sénateurs vont entrer
dans le vif du sujet avec l'examin des
articles concernant l'affirmation des
métropoles et plus particulièrement la
métropole parisienne mais les sénateurs
vont-ils continuer à réécrire le texte
du Gouvernement pour le savoir direction
l'hémicycle bonne séance à tous l'ordre
du jour appelle la suite de la
discussion du projet loi de
modernisation de l'action publique
territoriale et d'affirmation des
métropoles dans la discussion des
articles nous sommes parvenus à
l'article 10 et sur l'article 10 j'ai
une demande de parole la parole est
donnée à Monsieur philippe
Dallier merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames les ministres messieurs les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues bien
voilà le moment venu dans cet hémicycle
fort rempli nous allons donc pouvoir
discuter du sort du Grand
Paris je voudrais tout d'abord revenir
sur ce que nous avions fait en 2010 et
redire deux mots du
pourquoi notamment sur la petite
couronne et le fait qu'à l'époque un
amendement que j'avais présenté avait
été adopté à l'unanimité par le Sénat je
le rappelle et non pas en pleine nuit
comme j'avais pu le lire je crois que
c'était en fin de matinée et j'avais et
oui je le dis mon cher collègue parce
que j'ai tout entendu depuis et j'en ai
même entendu certains me reprocher
d'avoir ralenti les choses avec cet
amendement dans la loi de 2010 qui
effectivement n'imposait pas à la petite
couronne l'obligation de bouclage de la
carte d'intercommunalité pourquoi est-ce
que le Sénat m'avait suivi je pense que
la raison est est très simple à l'époque
le texte parlait bien des métropoles
mais il excluait l'Île-de-France de la
réflexion qui nous était proposée donc à
partir du moment où l'Île-de-France
était exclu dans l'attente d'un futur
texte sur le Grand Paris il me semblait
assez normal que l'on nimpose pas à la
première couronne parisienne le bouclage
de la carte intercommunale donc voilà ce
que je voulais rappeler en préambule à
notre débat il n'y avait rien d'autre
là-dessous maintenant j'avais tout de
même fait remarquer à l'Assemblée à
l'époque que si la carte intercommunale
n'était que très peu développée dans la
première couronne parisienne il y avait
certainement des raisons qu'il fallait
s'interroger sur ces raisons la première
c'est que le territoire ne ressemble pas
à à rien de comparable en fait ailleurs
en France et si l'intercommunalité a du
sens bien évidemment en province autour
des villes centre si elle a du sens en
grande couronne en Île-de-France parce
qu'effectivement le territoire est d'une
toute autre nature que dans la zone
dense et bien on a là l'explication les
élus malgré la carotte de la dotation
qui existait depuis 1999 n'avaient pas
vraiment trouvé utile d'aller vers
l'intercommunalité il faut rappeler cela
et rappeler également que si nous avons
deux ou trois beaux exemples
d'intercommunalité dans la première
couronne parisienne il faut rappeler
pourquoi ces exemples se sont développés
parce qu'il faudrait pas non plus que
dans le débat sur cet article 10 ça soit
un peu l'arbre qui cache la forêt il y a
deux ou trois exemples
d'intercommunalité qui fonctionnent mais
où sont-ils ces exemples ils sont
effectivement situés dans des grands
pôles d'attractivité économique exemple
autour de la défense exemple autour du
stade de France on comprend bien qu'à
ces endroits où l'État d'ailleurs a
massivement investi il faut le rappeler
et lorsqu'il y avait des opportunités en
matière de friche notamment dans les
anciens tissus industriel et bien les
élus effectivement ont trouvé une
logique de territoire mais dans tout le
reste de la première couronne parisienne
cette logique de territoire n'existe pas
vraiment et lorsque vous regardez un
département comme le mien celui de la
scè Saint-Denis vous verrez
qu'aujourd'hui on a trois
intercommunalités donc cell autour du
stade de France une qui s'est développée
de pentin à Montreuil en allant jusqu'à
bondi mais si vous regardez ce que les
élus font en intercommunalité madame la
ministre ils ne font pas grand-chose on
est encore assez près la coquille vide
serait peut-être un mot un peu trop fort
mais en tous les cas il n'y a pas de
vraie logique de territoire et puis il y
a l'intercommunalité historique de
cliché Montfermeil qui a été à l'époque
imposé pour le grand projet de
rénovation urbaine et c'était tout et
donc on a là un territoire qui ne se
prête pas à l'intercommunalité comme on
la vit ailleurs en France en province et
comme on peut la vivre également en
grande couronne en Île-de-France donc je
ne pense pas que de nous imposer dans
les mêmes conditions effectivement
l'intercommunalité qu'ailleurs soit une
bonne idée alors je comprends madame la
ministre que cette idée c'est celle
c'est le point de départ de votre projet
puisqueeffectivement le Grand Paris
Métropole que vous nous proposez il
s'appuie comme étant un niveau
supplémentaire par rapport à ces
intercommunalités vous que vous
souhaitez boucler mais pour autant je ne
considère pas que ça soit la la voie
dans laquelle il fait y aller parce que
si nous allons dans cette voie-là la
métropole intégrée comme je la
souhaiterais effectivement sur la zone
la plus resserrée de l'Île-de-France
elle deviendra impossible en tous les
cas par fusion des départements euh et
de ces collectivités locales de rang
inférieur voilà mes chers collègues ce
que je souhaitais rappeler en préambule
de ce débat euh parce que je trouve que
les propos que j'avais pu tenir ici en
2010 sur les métropoles et notamment sur
l'île-de-fance ont souvent été déformé
ce que j'ai regretté merci chers collègu
j'ai une demande de parole de Roger
carouci monsieur le Président Mesdames
les ministres je je mes chers collègues
je serai assez bref dans la mesure où je
vais défendre un amendement
immédiatement après la discussion sur
l'article au-delà de de ce que vient de
dire brillamment philippe Dallier que je
partage
totalement parce que même si on n pas
forcément d'accord sur le périmètre mais
je ve je peux avancer vers ça parce que
à un moment il faudra sortir de du cadre
actuel mais en tout état de cause
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'on nous dit et
qu'est-ce qu'on nous propose et là je
m'adresse vraiment à tous les élus de la
Haute Assemblée très au-delà de
l'île-defance nous sommes tous tous ici
d'où que nous venions des défenseurs des
communes nous sommes tous des défenseurs
des libertés communales de l'autonomie
communale ce texte est un texte
pardon je ne dirais pas de violation de
ces libertés mais en tout cas de
contrainte on nous dit
voilà pour réaliser la future métropole
de Paris on va vous imposer aujourd'hui
dans les 2 ans qui viennent de mettre en
place des établissements publics d'au
moins de 200000
habitants ça veut dire que là où il y a
eu un effort et il y en a qui existe moi
par exemple dans le département des
Hautes scèes il y a une très grande
intercommunalité dans le Sud qui fait à
peu près 200000 habitants donc celle-là
GPSO ça ira sauf qu'il y en a d'autres
qui ont été créés par des discussions
des négociations gauche droit entre des
villes voisines qui se sont dit on va
travailler ensemble mais elles ne sont
pas à ce niveau-là elles sont pas 200000
habitants donc on est en train de leur
dire ben vous êtes bien gentil vous avez
négocié des mois des années pour
parvenir à un accord mais c'est pas
comme ça que ça se passe il faut
renégocier il faut changer il faut
fusionner avec d'autres il faut ajouter
il faut retrouver d'autres solutions
pour arriver à ce seuil et la réalité
c'est
que les élus les maires disent attendez
c'est très difficile Philippe a raison
Philippe pardon a raison c'est très
difficile dans nos départements de
proche courouronne par exemple pourquoi
bah parce que un département comme les
hautes scènes c'est 1500000 habitants je
n'ai que 36 communes donc ça veut dire
de très grosses communes riches
puissantes qui dès qu'on leur dit il
faut aller en intercommunalité dis B
dites pourquoi je suis assez puissant
comme ça je me débrouille très bien tout
seul donc les négociation pour aboutir à
une intercommunaité sont difficiles et
on nous dit maintenant que les efforts
qui ont été réalisé en valdeemarne en
haute scène en sains pour arriver à des
choses à des solutions et bien il faut
tout revoir tout remettre à plat parce
que ça ne va
pas comment voulez-vous dire que vous
respectez la liberté des communes que
vous respectez l'autonomie communale que
vous respectez que on va mettre les
communes chef de fil sur un certain
nombre de sujets quand d'une part vous
allez en partie les désaisir au profit
d'établissement public mais quand plus
vous leur dites et vous n'avez pas le
choix de vos intercommunalités parce que
les choix que vous avez opérés jusqu'ici
ne correspondent pas aux critères qu'on
établit et par conséquent vous devez
changer modifier supprimer tous les
effort que vous avez fait depuis des
années pour réaliser ce que vous avez
réalisé il y a là quelque
chose j'allais dire
d'unensé autant il y a des logiques si
on dit on fusionne les quatre
départements mais on laisse les communes
il y a une logique
si on dit on laisse la région telle
quelle et on met les communes et les
départements il y a une logique mais la
logique qui consiste à dire sous la
contrainte on va forcer les communes à
se regrouper même si elles ont des
regroupements antérieurs et que ces
regroupements ne correspondent pas à
cela c'est vraiment une aberration à la
fois politique et là quelle que soit la
couleur politique des mares comment
voulez-vous qu'ils acceptent ça comment
voulez-vous expliquer à des populations
que depuis 1 an 2 ans 3 ans 4 ans vous
êtes en intercommunalité avec telle
commune et telle commune mais que B
voilà ça marche très bien mais on va le
casser comment vous allez expliquer ça
c'est inexplicable et c'est un fondement
faussé de la future métropole de Paris
j'aurai l'occasion de le redire
rapidement sur l'amendement de
suppression mais
sincèrement métropole de Paris pourquoi
pas sur de tels fondements sûrement
pas j'ai une demande de parole monsieur
capocanel
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président Mesdames les ministres je vais
exprimer ici le point de vue que j'ai
commencé à exprimer l des discussion
général qui est de dire que je suis
favorable au développement de l'interco
en Île-de-France je pense que c'est
nécessaire et nous devons le faire au
rythme francilien mais ce rythme de de
mon point de vue ne peut pas être
uniquement le pied sur le frein et il y
a un retard je pense qu'il nous faut le
combler il faut tenir compte des
éléments très spécifique à
l'île-de-fance mais sur l'objectif il
faut à la fois assurer la métropole et
je pense que la première étape c'est
trouver les voies et moyens pour
permettre à l'intercommunalité de se
développer en île-de-fance de structurer
réellement le territoire et de le faire
en première couronne il me semble que
c'est nécessaire et puis après on aura à
regarder comment la métropole peut se
construire le point désaccord très fort
avec le gouvernement sur la méthode je
crois que en fixant la toise à 300000
c'était donné un seuil
atteignable j'entends bien le
raisonnement pardon un peu techno qui
est de dire il faut des grosses interc
parce que ça marche mieux en même temps
Philippe Da dit Roger carucci aussi à
l'instant il faut quand même trouver des
logiques de territoire je prendis qu'un
exemple que je connais le moins mal qui
le mien nous sommes autour de l'aéroport
du Bourget une communauté de 92000
habitants on peut monter en gros à 142
145000 habitants et puis après on va
basculer sur un tout autre projet de
territoire et après le sens des plus
même et après la population ne sait même
pas la ville dont on va parler de quoi
il s'agit elle sait vaguement qu'elle
existe bien évidemment elle traverse à
l'occasion mais il n'y a pas d'intérêt
commun il y a pas de communauté
d'intérêt il y a pas de communauté
d'aménagement on est sur des territoires
qui n'ont pas de problématique commune
donc ce seuil là à 300000 me semblait
tout à fait aberrant la commission des
lois a proposé de le ramener à 200 et je
pense que c'est déjà une bonne chose moi
j'ai t à dire qu' les 200 il faut
pouvoir les moduler il peut y avoir des
cas où les communes vont monter ensemble
à 180000 on va leur dire non vous êtes
pas encore à toise encore un petit peu
plus il me semble que il faut aussi
intégrer je défendrai par amendement la
logique du schéma directeur qui a repris
une partie de la logique du Grand Paris
et des CDT et les contrats de
développement territorial fixent une
armature à l'Île-de-France fixent des
stratégies france-ilennes il faut
d'abord que nous ayons ce débat làà
qu'est-ce que nous voulons faire de
l'île-de-fance autour de quels
équipements au autour de quelle voie
routière autour de quel bassin d'emploi
au cours de tel quel projet collectif
nous voulons la structurer à partir de
ça on arrivera à trouver des bassins de
vie et je suis d'accord avec philippe
Dallier c'est beaucoup plus difficile de
les dessiner mais il y a un travail qui
a été fait il est repris en bonne part
maintenant dans le zrif il va être fixé
dans les CDT qui sont en cours de
discussion c'est à partir d'une vision
de l'île-de-fance parce que si on dit
l'intercommunalité n'est qu'une vision
techno et juridique ça marchera pas il
faut qu'on arrive à dire avec les élus
on fait l'interco pourquoi pour plus
d'emplois pour mieux se déplacer pour
des équipements pour améliorer la
qualité de vie pour faire que en sainsis
certains territoires soient désenclavés
notamment voilà la démarche et c'est
autour de ce projet là qui nous faut
construire donc je pense que laatoise à
300 cétait pas bonne à 200 je proposerai
de l'amender pour tenir compte justement
des CDT du SDRIF des projets de
territoire il faut cet aspect là
qualitatif sinon ça sera vraiment tout
le monde à la norme et rien que la norme
alors ma CIN simplement c'est que si
nous choisissons aujourd'hui de
repousser l'échéance un et Roger carouci
l'a dit ça n'est pas d'ailleurs de très
bonnes politique par rapport au
territoires qui ont commencé parce que
finalement on va finir par se dire ah
ben ceux qui ont commencé il n'it pas
pas de raison de commencer si en plus
ceuxl on les pénalisé en disant c'est
200 ils vont se dire finalement quelle
confiance pourons-nous avoir dans la loi
la loi c'était on peut en Île-deFrance
constituer interco et puis alors qu'on
vient de les créer on nous dira ah ben
non non vous avez pas compris c'était à
200 qu'il fallait aller bon on peut pas
changer la règle tout le temps donnons
envie de faire l'interco bâtissonsla sur
les projets territoire dernier point euh
que je voulais euh aborder euh je veux
simplement dire que euh
je crois que ça ne soit plus dur encore
demain si on trouve pas une solution
aujourd'hui moi j'ai envie de dire au
gouvernement à vous d'amender à vous
d'essayer de proposer une voie qui soit
acceptable par les territoires c'est me
semble-t-il la démarche qu'il nous faut
essayer de trouver cet après-midi mais
ça ne peut pas être sur la base qui est
proposé ni par le gouvernement ni à ce
stade par la commission je vous mercie
merci chers collègu la parole est à
Monsieur
café merci Monsieur le le président avec
cet article 10 nous entamons laussion
générale sur l'ensemble de ce que
certains appellent la métropole
parisienne en tout cas la problématique
générale de la gouvernance en
île-de-fance c'est un sujet qui est
extrêmement compliqué c'est un sujet qui
est débattu depuis maintenant des années
et des années qui a fait l'objet de
discussion au travers de nombreux
rapports au travers d'un certain nombre
d'institutions je pense notamment à
parismétropole qui n'a pas abouti à
trouver une solution commune mais je me
demande si Franch nous abordons la
question par le bon
bout c'està-dire en fait celui du mécano
institutionnel car nous sommes dans la
discussion du mécano institutionnel or
très franchement quel est le sujet de
l'île de France et de la
métropole pour moi en tout cas ce sujet
est le suivant c'est que nous avons à
faire face à un certain nombre de
problèmes de gouvernance qui pèse sur
l'efficacité d'un certain nombre de
politiques publiques et quand je parle
de politique publique j'ai en tête
évidemment les plus structurante bien
évidemment qui sont celles par exemple
du développement économique et de
l'emploi de l'organisation des
transports ou du logement il y a bien
d'autres politiques publiques mais
commençons par nous intéresser en fait à
ce qui structure véritablement le
territoire et l'aménagement de
l'île-de-fance et puis regardons ce qu'
est possible de faire sur un certain
nombre d'autres politiques publiques qui
de mon point de vue n'engag pas l'avenir
de notre région ou de notre métropole
donc c'est ça que je voulais dire au
départ ne nous focalisons pas sur le
mécano institutionnel ou sur tel ou tel
en fait mécanisme de mécano alors
Monsieur Dalier je sais bien
que vous avez fait un rapport qui a fait
date d'ailleurs le rapport de la
commission des lois vous rend hommage et
loin de moi l'idée de dire que
l'amendement que vous aviez présenté à
l'époque en 2010 a été un facteur
bloquant mais qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
en 2010 en 2010 un certain nombre
d'évolutions de la petite couronne
parisienne lui ont été
interdites
celui mais bien sûr que si attendez
bon enfin la la Petite Couronne a été
exonérée comme le reste du territoire on
avait l'obligation de terminer
l'intercommunalité et si je me souviens
bien il a été interdit à la région Île
de France même pas la petite couronne de
fonder de créer une métropole voire même
un pôle métropolitain je ne dis pas
monsieur Dalier que c'est vous encore
une fois si vous pensez que je vous fais
cette accusation loin de moi cette
idée le problème est quoi le problème
est lequel bon c'est que nous avons un
problème de gouvernance fondamentale en
île-de- France et que jusqu'à présent
personne ne sait comment le prendre car
il y a deux manières de régler ce
problème de gouvernance et
d'organisation du territoire en
île-de-fance il y a celle que vous
suggérez monsieur Dalier la fusion des
département mais qui ne serait qu'une
première étape pour aller vers une une
espèce de communauté urbaine ou de
métropole intégré doté de compétences
spécifiques en terme limités bien
évidemment mais de compét sur son
territoire
bon écoutez force de constater que à
l'heure actuelle cette proposition n'a
pas prospéré ni sur ses bans ni sur les
vôtres c'est un peu la raison pour mais
nous verrons ça lors des votes sur les
amendements que vous que vous déposez
monsieur daliier peut-être puis-je me
tromper enfin nous verrons en fait le le
résultat des votes sur vos
amendements c'est une voix que aucun
enfin que très peu d'élus d'île-de
France ou qu'une infime minorité des
élus d'Île-de- France ont choisi de
suivre voilà la situation dans laquelle
nous
sommeson or le problème de l'efficacité
des politiques publiques et de la
gouvernance de ces politiques publiques
reste entier d'où l'idée suivante si
nous ne pouvons pas avancer ensemble
vers une communauté intégrée dont je
reconnais d'ailleurs qu'elle aurait un
certain nombre d'intérêt celui par
exemple de régler la question des
péquations en petite couronne celui par
exemple d'unifier les politiques sociale
en petite couronne je le reconnais mais
reconnaissez aussi avec moi monsieur
Dallier que jusqu'à présent personne ne
vous a suivi donc qu'est-ce que nous
faisons est-ce que nous
j'en termine est-ce que nous restons sur
le statut qu ou est-ce que nous essayons
d'avancer vers une autre solution
laquelle solution qui est proposée par
le gouvernement et ma fois j'aurais
préféré je le dis une are solution un
peu plus contraignante c'est de celui
c'est celle pardon une solution
consistant à avancer sur la résolution
des problèmes de gouvernance d'un
certain nombre de politique publique et
notamment celle du logement qui font
gravement défaut en Île-de France merci
chers collègu la parole est à Madame
Goulet
oui monsieur le Président Madame le
ministre mes chers collègues permettez
un sénateur très rural qui n'aura
probablement pas l'occasion de beaucoup
s'exprimer cet après-midi de de réagir à
ce qui à ce qui vient d'être dit car les
arguments
que que notre collègue carucci a
développé avec beaucoup de talent sont
exactement ce que nous pauvres élus de
territoires ruraux avons développé
longuement pendant pendant le le le
débat pendant le débat sur la loi du 16
décembre 2010 en expliquant que
d'ailleurs dans un département comme le
mien qui était couvert à 90 % par
l'intercommunalité qu'il fallait laisser
du temps au temps qu'il ne fallait pas
pousser les choses qu'il qu'il fallait
respecter
l'autonomie des des
collectivités le gouvernement nous avait
donné des assurances sur le seuil de
5000 habitants sur le fait qu'on aurait
des dérogations sur le fait que la carte
intercommunale que les schéma ne seraiit
pas fait au canon et c'est pas du tout
ce qui s'est passé donc quand j'entends
ça je me dis vraiment que nous soyons
puissant ou ou misérable et évidemment
Paris mais Paris intéresse tout le monde
parce que le Grand Paris va jusqu'à la
Normandie donc c'est normal que les élus
normand et René gareg soient là aussi
pour voir ce qui se passe à Paris c'est
tout à fait c'est tout à fait important
pour pour nous mais mais très
franchement Monsieur kucci Je je
j'aimerais j'aurais aimé que que le
Sénat et et que la loi prête plus
d'attention aussi aux petites communes
qui notamment dans le bouclage des
schémas
intercommunaux ont quand même beaucoup
beaucoup de de déconvenus c'était
simplement l'objet de de mon
intervention et ça permettra aux élus
qui viennent de boucler chez moi le le
schéma
intercommunal de comprendre que la loi
n'a pas été faite pour eux merci chers
collègues la parole est à Monsieur
del
oui monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre et mes chers collègues je
voudrais rappeler à ma collègue Goulet
que en Île-de-France aussi il y a des
des petites communes hein il n'y a pas
que des grandes communes il y a des
communes de 60 habitants en île-de-fance
donc on a tout types de communes et moi
je trouve un peu surréaliste de
commencer la discussion de ce projet de
loi sur une taille
d'intercommunalité donc c'est vrai que
la taille d'intercommunalité ça devrait
venir à la fin une fois qu'on a une
vision claire de l'organisation générale
de notre territoire et non pas dès le
départ là on commence à discuter de
savoir si c'est 300 200 et euh je ne
sais combien de de de milliers de
d'habitants alors que je ne vois pas
dans ce texte malheureusement une vision
claire de l'avenir de l'organisation de
notre territoire on la voit pour la
région lyonnaise peut-être un peu aussi
pour la région marseillaise en tout cas
pour la région parisienne on la voit pas
du tout et on ne la sent pas et moi
c'est ce qui me gêne dans ce texte c'est
qu'on a l'impression que on ne choisit
pas on rajoute une structure euh qui
vient un peu de Paris-Métropole alors on
nous dit Paris-Métropole n'a pas réussi
à se mettre d'accord mais ça me surprend
pas moi j'ai j'ai participé aux deux
premières réunions de Paris Métropole
parce que je croyais un petit peu que
c'était intéressant de essayer de
s'organiser discuter entre collectivités
mais quand j'ai vu la façon dont les
débats étaient organisés je me suis dit
au bout de réunions il n'en sortira rien
et je ne suis pas revenu c'est vrai et
finalement il en est rien sorti donc
j'ai bien fait de pas passer du temps et
de consacrer du temps à à ces réunions
et malheureusement je crois qu'on n' pas
de cahier décharges clair sur ce sur
quoi nous devrions travailler et ce sur
quoi nous devrions concerter nos élus
parce que les élus de nos petites
communes de l'Île-de-France ils n'ont
absolument pas été concertés ils sont
complètement surpris par ce texte et
aujourd'hui je pense que la sagesse du
gouvernement et si le le Sénat pouvait
passer une une partie de cette sagesse
au gouvernement ça serait de retirer la
partie Île-de-France de ce texte de
donner un délai de concertation aux élus
de la Région Île de France qui sont pas
idiots qui ont aussi un peu
d'intelligence et qui peuvent peut-être
sur un délis fixés par le gouvernement
essayer de se mettre d'accord sur une
formule qui soit acceptée par tout le
monde et ensuite si s'il n'y arrive pas
si au bout d'un an un an et demi il n'y
arrive pas là dans ces cas-là le
gouvernement propose sa vision mais ici
on n pas de
choix on voit qu'on ne choisit pas on
rajoute une structure ça va nous coûter
cher hein parce que la fin d'Interco en
Île-de-France c'est quand même sur
2013204 de 100 à 120 millions d'euros
qui vont être prélevés sur l'ensemble
des autres collec ité en France donc
c'est pas c'est pas négligeable et tout
cela sans avoir réglé aucun problème on
aura une métropole qui va établir un
plan du logement en même temps que la
région va faire un schéma régional de
logement et de l'hébergement il faut il
faut me dire un peu ce que ça va
apporter en plus je je ne le vois pas
aujourd'hui alors moi j'ai peut-être une
vision un peu simpliste je vais
peut-être un petit peu plus loin que
philippe Dallier sur le sujet mais moi
je pense qu'il faut faire des choix et
moi je suis d'accord pour une métropole
mais qu'elle ne s'arrête pas à 10
millions d'habitants puisque la région
en a 12 je vois pas pourquoi on
laisserait une partie il y aurait 2
millions d'habitants en île-de-fance qui
seraient perdus dans C cas là faisons
une vraie métropole supprimons la région
euh faisons des grandes intercommunités
parce que moi je suis pour des grandes
intercommunités et laissons aux communes
pas mal de pouvoirs parce que les
communes elles souhaitent conserver des
pouvoirs donc si on avait cette
organisation là et et je pense qu'on
doit pouvoir en un an ou en 18 mois se
mettre d'accord en Île-de-France sur
cette organisation et ensuite revenir
devant le Parlement effectivement avec
un projet comme celui de Lyon où la loi
transcrit quoi le gouvernement transcrit
dans la loi le l'accord qui a été fait
sur le plan local et qui est un accord
intelligent voilà moi je pense qu'on
peut faire preuve aussi d'intelligence
en Île-de-France laissez-nous un tout
petit peu de temps Madame la Ministre et
puis ensuite on reprendra ce débat voilà
dans un Anou dans un an et demi avec un
accord sur le fond plutôt que d'aller
bricoler comme on va le faire ici et un
bricolage qui va nous coûter cher voilà
mes chers collègues ce que je pense au
début de cet article merci chers collègu
la parle par à Madame
lipiè merci monsieur le Président c'est
vrai qu'avant de de commencer à nous
interroger sur la métropole du Grand de
Paris ou du Grand Paris on peut se
demander ce quelle l' Île de France
Pourquoi est-ce que Paris où
s'arrêterait Paris est-ce que je peux
dire que les habitants de l'Est de la
scèémarne qui vont travailler à la
défense en traversant tous les matins
Paris sont-ils moins parisiens que ceux
qui viennent de sud de l'esson ou de
l'ouest du valdoise je suis assez étonné
sauf erreur de ma
part nous sommes quand même trois
départements de la grande couronne peu
de sénateurs de ces départements sont
présents pourquoi peu j'ai pas dit que
personne j'ai bien dit peu il manque
comment les meilleurs sont là certes
mais les autres où sont-ils est-ce que
peut-être parce que justement il
représente le problème fondamental de ce
texte à savoir que les élus de la grande
pardon les habitants de la grande
couronne se sentent totalement délaissé
par ce texte ne sachant pas où est leur
place alors même que ils sont au premier
chef intéressés par le développement du
Grand Paris qui risque de se faire à
leur leur détriment ont-ils l'impression
et je crois qu'il y a réellement une
nécessité d'envisager globalement et
j'ai nos amendements chez écologistes
reviendront là-dessus d'envisager
globalement les les circulations d'idées
de politique entre la petite couronne
Paris centre et la grande couronne et ce
texte pour le moment n'a pas cette
ambition merci merci chers collèguees la
parole est à Monsieur
Favier monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre mes chers collègues euh nous y
reviendrons évidemment dans nos
amendements sur la métropole de Paris
mais peut-être quelques mots aussi sur
la la réflexion générale qui qui
s'engage pour nous il s'agit pas de de
de méconnaître la la réalité
métropolitaine de Paris parce que s'il y
a effectivement une région en France qui
peut prétendre je pense effectivement à
à ce à ce terme de métropole c'est bien
la région parisienne mais pour autant la
méthode employée pour avancer ne n
paraît pas la bonne et cela pour
plusieurs pour plusieurs raisons
d'abord notre collègue Dalier l'a
rappelé il faut se rappeler qu' en 2010
effec effectivement le
lorsque le le Parlement n'a pas autorisé
effectivement l'Île-de-France à achever
la carte intercommunale c'est parce
qu'il y avait effectivement cette
proposition de fusion des trois
départements de la petite couronne et
Paris pour essayer de créer une grande
communauté urbaine et il est évident
qu'à ce moment-là ça faisait disparaître
dans ce périmètrre là les
intercommunalités existantes or on était
dans un mouvement au contraire de
développement des intercommunalités et
donc la question n'a pas n' pas érer et
par ailleurs il faut bien reconnaître
que beaucoup d'arguments ont été aussi
développés pour montrer les dangers
aussi d'une telle proposition qui aurait
créé une véritable coupure entre le cœur
le plus dense effectivement de
l'agglomération parisienne mais aussi
qui concentre aussi les plus fortes
richesses il faut bien le dire même si
elle concentre aussi beaucoup de
difficultés et le reste de
l'île-de-fance et on aura eu une vraie
coupure effectivement entre petite et
grande couronne ce qui était à juste
titre rejeté par bon nombre de nos des
nos collègues par ailleurs il faut bien
reconnaître aussi que le achever la
carte intercommunale en Île-de-France
c'est plus compliqué qu'ailleurs pour
une raison simple c'est que il n'y a pas
dans les départements de petite couronne
à proprement parler de ville centre je
prends mon l'exemple de mon département
mais c'est vrai pour les hautes scènes
aussi pour la scne saintenis il y a des
des villes certaines d'ailleurs
importantes 80 100000 habitants et qui
d'ailleurs et la moyenne des ville ont
plus de 40000 habitants donc beaucoup
d'entre elles ont d'ors et déjà souvent
des services suffisamment développés
couvre beaucoup de leurs compétences et
donc forcément ça rend plus compliqué le
développement d'une intercommunalité par
ailleurs il y a déjà des coopérations
existant importantes au-delà des
intercours déjà existantes il y a aussi
toutes les coopérations dans des
syndicats qui euh sur des compétences
très importantes il y a le syndicat des
transports î-de-france quand même qui
existe mais il y a aussi sur
l'électricité c'est vrai aussi sur le
traitement des déchets c'est vrai c'est
vrai dans dans dans dans bien des
domaines et puis il y a des syndicats
comme des syndicats dans le domain de la
restauration collective et cetera toutes
ces structures globalement ne
fonctionnent pas mal elles fonctionnent
plutôt bien peut-être que sans doute
leur périmètre méritera à l'avenir
peut-être d'être étendu d'être mieux
coordonné mais pourquoi tout chamboul
euh alors qu'on a quand même des
structures qui déjà aujourd'hui
fonctionnent bien et sur lequel il faut
prendre au contraire à mon avis appui
pour avoir une vision une construction
de de de l'île-de-fance euh il y a
également des coopérations même lorsque
on n'est pas allé jusqu al interco il y
a un certain nombre de collectivités
également qui ont développé déjà des
coopérations assez étendues en terme de
syndicat d'études je pense par exemple
nous on a dans l'est parisien à cheval
sur la scène saint-is et le valde
mararne une association des des communes
de l'Est parisien qui ont développé
qu'on appelle l'ctet qui ont développé
des coopérations et des réflexions
communes et qui travaillent de déjà
depuis un certain temps tout cela il
faut pas vouloir à mon avis forcément
balayer ce travail là et vouloir avancer
à marche forcé dans l'achèvement de
cette carte intercommunale surtout sur
la base de critères qui à mon avis me
paraissent très contestable le chiffre
de 300000 habitants est extrêmement
arbitraire alors certes on nous dit
effectivement on travaille mieux à cette
échelle-là mais pourquoi pourquoi 300000
pourquoi 300000 300000 habitants moi je
pense qu'il faut surtout regarder
d'abord le projet sur quelle base sur
quel projet ont construit effectivement
ces intercommunalités alors pourquoi pas
il peut y avoir des communautés
d'agglomération 300000 habitants mais il
y a il y a beaucoup qui travaillent
aujourd'hui sur des réalités différentes
par exemple en prenant en compte compte
ce qu'on appelle le contrat de
développement territorial qui est né du
réseau du Grand Paris Express et
aujourd'hui on voit des communes qui de
manière plus récente travaill ensemble à
des projets de territoire à partir de
l'arrivée du futur du futur métro c'est
le cas dans mon département et des
communes de sensibilité différentes ma
commune par exemple le champign
travaille avec la commune de Villier la
commune de Briis sur ce contrat de
développement territorial et envisage
une intercommunalité mais c'est pas une
intercommunalité de 300000 habitants à
l'évidence et pour autant il y a un vrai
projet de territoire avec des intérêts
communs pour
développer le développer économiquement
le territoire créer de l'emploi et
répondre aussi à des besoins des besoins
de logement donc je pense que dans la
méthode je pense qu' il y a pas besoin
de vouloir avancer à marche força si ce
n'est qu'il peut y avoir parfois
certaines arrière-pensées politiques moi
je je veux le dire ici pour le groupe
que je représente mais quand on fait des
intercommunalités effectivement limité à
300000 habitants bah forcément le
spectre politique se réduit évidemment à
essentiellement à de à deux partis
politiques alors que la diversité
politique en Île-de-France on le sait
est beaucoup plus importante et beaucoup
plus large elle ne se résume pas
simplement à l'existence de l'UMP et du
Parti socialiste donc moi je pense
queeffectivement il faut travailler donc
à un rythme à un
rythme différent et
enfin on dit il y a des problèmes de
gouvernance j'entends notre collègue qui
a fait sur en région parisienne sur la
question du logement alors je je serai
évidemment le dernier à contester euh
l'importance du problème du logement je
le vis dans mon territoire avec 60000
demandeurs de logement et avec les
difficultés que nous avons de répondre à
leur à leurs demande je ne suis pas je
le dit très clairement convaincu
qu'aujourd'hui le processus tel qu'il
est engagé dans la réforme et avec y
compris toutes les modalités qui sont
prévues nous permettront de résoudre de
manière réactive et rapide à cette
question hein les procédures nous
rendent quand on met bout à bout les
procédures prévues c'est on on ne sera
pas opérationnel avant au moins 5 ans
euh alors donc je pense qu'il y a si on
est dans l'urgence par rapport au
logement je crois davantage
effectivement au débat que nous allons
avoir sur le la loi logement de de
Cécile Duflot où nous avons besoin
effectivement d'avancer très vite sur
des questions par exemple foncières pour
rendre disponible effectivement pour les
opérateurs de construction du logement
social aujourd'hui des disponibilité
plus importante en la matière ou
d'autres dispositifs mais nous mais je
pense que la métropole évidemment on
doit se préoccuper de cette question du
logement ne croyons pas et ne créons pas
l'illusion que parce que nous allons
créer la métropole nous allons résoudre
ce problème ce problèmelà et par
ailleurs je pense qu'on résoudra pas le
problème du logement par un
désengagement de l'État je pense que et
en particulier à l'égard des communes
aujourd'hui carencées en matière de
l'agurance sociale qui n'appliquent pas
la loi et ses ru je pense que c'est pas
la métropole qui imposera d'autres des
collectivités donc qui imposeront à
d'autres la manière de gérer leur
territoire je pense que à un moment
donné le régulérateur c'est l'état on la
matière qui doit jouer son rôle merci
chers collègues la parole est à Madame
procacia merci monsieur le Président le
Christian Favier a très bien expliqué un
certain nombre de choses comme Philippe
Dalier comme Roger carucci en 2010 je
faisais partie de celle qui défendait
effectivement cette cet amendement qui
est passé et qui permettait à l'î-de-
France d'attendre et d'attendre de
savoir ce que devenait le Grand Paris
mais aussi il y avait une préoccupation
des élus qui était il faut qu'on en
discute avec les citoyens et avec nos
nos citoyens et les personnes qui vivent
avec nous et l'occasion d'en discuter
c'était effectivement de présenter un
projet à l'occasion des municipal de
2014 quel projet voulez-vous que les
maires puissent présenter là en 2014 là
on est à 1 an des élection et on va leur
dire on va rentrer vous allez devoir
rentrer dans une interco non pas une
Inter qui aurait été négocié mais une
interco qui est une interco purement
mathématique on doit arriver à 300000
selon Madame la Ministre à 200000 selon
la commission mais ça va se traduire par
quoi on va dire on met X Y Z à zut comme
le disait mon collègue du Bourget tout à
l'heure on arrive à 180000 et ben c'est
pas bon on arrive à 270000 il va falloir
prendre un bout d'ailleurs mais c'est
une une
aberration en outre la difficulté en
tout cas pour des départements et des
communes qui sont comme les miennes
proche d'un grand voisin un peu
encombrant monsieur café qui est Paris
comment voulez-vous quand on est quand
on joue Paris qu'on puisse envisager
sereinement des intercommunalités on n'a
pas le choix on n'est pas au milieu d'un
département on est contre Paris avec
lequel on ne peut rien faire et qui
toutes les façons nous impose plus
j'interviens parce que je ne sais pas en
plus quel va être le sort des premiers
amendements mais en 2010 au moins le
Sénat avait eu la sagesse de tenir
compte de la topographie la topographie
c'est que Paris il ressemble un peu à
Micky il a deux grandes oreilles à l'Est
et à l'Ouest avec le bois de Vincen et
le bois de Boulogne or
quand dans votre texte vous interdisez
que des commune d'un seul tenant
puisse doivent être d'un seul tenant et
bien ça veut dire que vous condamnez
géographiquement même votre
intercommunalité parce que
l'intercommunalité pour la partie qui me
concerne autour du bois et ben elle va
se faire où on est coincé par Paris on
est coincé tout il y a six communes qui
ne touche que le bois de vin scè et qui
ne touche que que la scène saintnique
comment on fait une interco alors vous
nous imposez 200000 ou 300000 habitants
et vous tenez même pas compte de la
topographie donc tout à l'heure je
présenterai un sous-amendement mais on
sait jamais le sort donc je voudrais
demander tout de suite à Messieurs les
rapporteurs à monsieur le Président et à
madame la ministre en tout cas en deème
lecture d'essayer de tenir compte de
d'éléments objectifs qui avait été voté
par tout le monde en 2010 merci chers
collègu la parole est à Monsieur Nigre
vue de siryius ou à 1000 km de là je me
garderaai de rentrer dans les détails de
du fait urbain parisien mais je suis
interpellé par le périmètre tel qu'il
est
prévu parce que lorsqu'on aborde les
grands problèmes qui sont d'intérêt
collectif c'est-à-dire les services
comme l'assaainissement comme les
ordures ménagères comme les transports
on aurait me
semble-t-il besoin d'avoir des visions
d'ensemble exhaustive qui couvre à mon
sens à ce moment-là puisque déjà le
Grand Paris Métropole atteint les 100
millions pourquoi pas la région à 12
millions et là pourquoi faire compliquer
quand on peut faire simple pourquoi ne
pas avoir à ce moment-là une enveloppe
un périmètre qui correspond déjà à un
étage admin ratif aujourd'hui reconnu
avec ces haut et C bas mais sur lequel
tout le monde est calé pourquoi ne pas
s'engager dans une
simplification dans une
simplification dans une simplification
de périmètrre de périmètrre plutôt que
d'en avoir un autre supplémentaire pour
que plus personne s'y retrouve mais une
simplification de périmè ne signifie pas
pour autant chers collègues que il y ait
parce que j'ai bien compris que c'était
difficile effectivement de subdiviser et
sans compter la topographie comme notre
collègue l'a dit donc on a beaucoup de
difficultés à mettre quelque chose en
place mais pour autant pour autant j'ai
l'impression encore une fois vu de 1000
km hein je suis pas dedans mais de
l'extérieur qu'une vision d'ensemble de
type régional dans son périmètre avec
ces grands sujets d'intérêt commun
pourrai peut-être rassembler les uns et
les autres
chers collègues la parole est à Monsieur
rafarin monsieur le Président Mesdames
les ministres mes chers collègues juste
un mot ministre pour dire
que cette démarche que vous engagez ne
me paraît pas heureuse pour les
métropoles je suis élu d'un département
mi urbain mi rural sans énorme métropole
quand je regarde ce qui s'est passé dans
les 25 dernières années en terme
d'aménagement du territoire et
décentralisation l'émergence des
métropoles est un fait majeur qui est
pas facile à accepter pour tout le
territoire mais au fond si vous circulez
un petit peu partout en France vous
voyez que Lille Bordeaux Lyon Marseille
Toulouse Ren Nantes ces villes ont
changé leur environnement elles sont
d'abord devenues belles elles ont
revalorisé leur patrimoine elles sont
devenues accueillantes elles ont
organisé la mobilité ce qui fait que la
circulation dans ces villes est
extraordinaire et je ne sais pas
Monsieur le Maire Monsieur le Président
s'il y a 10 ans on aurait été passé un
weekend à Lyon pour aller à la fête des
lumières et aujourd'hui on va à Lyon
pour aller voir quand on est à
l'extérieur pour aller voir des
phénomènes de qui ce qu' ce qu'on va
quelquefis voir à l'étranger maintenant
on va voir chez nous c'est le cas de la
fête du fleuve aujourd'hui ou à Bordeaux
ou de la de la braderie de Lille il y a
aujourd'hui nos villes se sont embellli
c'est un phénomène qu'il faut regarder
parce que ces métropoles sont devenues
interrégionales elles sont quelqu part
sorti de leur région alors évidemment il
faut expliquer ce phénomène au pays et
c'est pas simple parce que naturellement
elles attirent parce que elles
inquiètent parce Queau fond c'est une
forme d'organisation territoriale un peu
Dang alors déjà commencer par ce sujet
dans cet acte 3 c'est déjà laisser
penser que les autres territoires vont
souffrir un peu parce que on prend ce
qui est dynamique comme premier sujet et
on a le sentiment que les autres sujets
viendront après c'est déjà un problème
mais le deuxième sujet c'est de mettre
Paris dans ce sujet-là parce que autant
on pourra expliquer ce qu'est
aujourd'hui à Lyon à Bordeaux ou
ailleurs une articulation entre une
région un département et au fond
l'intercommunalité autant c'est
difficile de mêler le cas parisien où
finalement il y a assez peu de
visibilité entre le rôle du département
le rôle de l'intercommunalité et avec
les schémas qui NT proposés la
différence entre la région et la ville
quand on va être avec un territoire qui
représente 95 % du territoire région
iale je comprends et j'approuve ce que
dit philippe Dallier pour aller
retrouver un peu de lisibilité mais on
voit bien qu'il y a une forme dans le
pays à la fois de réserve sur le cas
parisien qui ne sert pas le reste du
débat et d'autre part une spécificité du
cas parisien qui mériterait d'être
traité à part et vraiment je crois que
le débat par je ne suis pas un
spécialiste et j'écoute les uns et les
autres mais vu du point de vue de ceux
qui s'intéresse à la vie de nos
territoires et avec l'émergence des
métropoles et l'articulation de la
métropole avec les autres ire on a le
sentiment en prenant l'exemple parisien
que c'est une logique un peu au fond de
d'absorption un peu quelqu part un peu
hypertrophié alors que les villes
interrégionales n'apparaissent pas comme
des hypertrophies et elles ont au fond
en matière d'aménagement de
décentralisation une lisibilité qui font
que petit à petit les partenariats
s'articulent y compris même avec la
ruralité environnante donc simplement je
voulais vous dire que moi je crois que
c'est assez difficile dans notre pays
d'expliquer que ce que Olivier Guichard
rappelé les métropoles d'équilibre on
parle de ce concept de métropole depuis
très longtemps mais en fait il est
émergent dans notre pays depuis assez
peu de temps et au fond il faut le
conforter et il faut le valoriser mais
le valoriser non pas comme un élément
qui pourrait se mêler à Paris mais comme
au fond un élément de nature et local et
nationale parce que je pense qu'un des
sujets majeurs de notre économie
aujourd'hui c'est l'attractivité de
notre territoire et les métropoles
participent à l'attractivité de notre
territoire pour elle-même et pour leur
environnement et cette dynamique là il
faut pouvoir l'expliquer au pays avec
une certaine pédagogie parce que
naturellement à partir du moment où ces
territoires sont quelque part un peu
dominants il est clair que ça inquiète
les autres donc moi je suis pour une
pédagogie nationale de la métropole mais
pour cela s'il vous plaît essayons de
séparer le cas de Paris parce que le cas
de Paris est un cas tellement spécifique
et il a tellement au fond d'hostilité
que ce faisant et bien on freine le
reste de la dynamique alors que des gens
comme moi qui était réservé sur ces
phénomènes urbains il y a une dizaine ou
une quinzaine d'années aujourd'hui
constate la réussite de nos métropole
interrégionale et nous devons les
intégrer à une réflexion globale et de
l'Aménagement du Territoire et de la
Décentralisation merci Monsieur le
Premier Ministre la parole est à Madame
gourau
oui la
discussion pardon monsieur le Président
Mesdames les ministres mes chers
collègues
la discussion sur Paris est toujours un
peu compliquée mais je trouve bien que
les
provinciaux exprime ce qu'ils ressentent
la la première chose c'est
que peut-être contrairement à ce que
vient de dire le Premier ministre
Jean-Pierre affarin on a toujours fait
exception de Paris et je sais que c'est
particulier mais l'exception fait qu'il
s pas jamais rien ou pas grand-chose en
terme
d'intercommunalité alors attendez je
finis hein vous dirai après ce que vous
avez comme avis
euh
et on légifère en disant toujours Paris
est à part Paris ceci Paris cela
bien depuis 2010 l'intercommunalité
s'est un peu développée dans
l'île-de-fance la région parisienne mais
pas beaucoup et je me demande pourquoi
alors l'intercommunalité ne se développe
pas dans le
cadre du droit commun parce que rien
n'empêche aux
intercommunalités de se monter selon la
volonté des élus de l'île-de-fance parce
que on nous dit c'est pas 200000 c'est
300000 enfin je sais pas quoi c'est trop
petit c'est trop grand c'est pas comme
ça faut tenir tenir compte des réalités
mais il faut que les élus je je me
permets de dire locaux même s'ils sont
dans la région parisienne prennent leur
destin en main et essaient de construire
uire quelque chose parce que autrement
je veux dire c'est vrai pour n'importe
quel territoire et puis d'autre part il
faut que vous considériez que vous ne
vivez pas sur une île moi je suis dans
une région la région Centre l'île de
France a des implications extrêmement
importantes sur la vie
quotidienne des régions et des habitants
de de la région Centre tous ceux qui
bordent la région parisienne qu'il soit
de leur éloire ou du Loiré et cetera ont
des problèmes majeurs de transport parce
qu'ils vont pour la plupart travailler
sur l'agglomération parisienne enfin la
métropole parisienne je pense qu'il
enfin je veux dire on peut pas dire sans
arrêt que Paris
et la région parisienne sont à part je
je crois qu'il y a un moment où il faut
prendre le problème à bras-lecp même si
c'est notre capital à tous euh je je je
crois qu'il faut vraiment être dynamique
et je reconnais à à notre collègue
d'allier depuis euh des années euh de se
battre pour que tout cela euh bouge et
je crois que ça serait une erreur euh de
maintenir en l'état la situation de
Paris et de la région parisienne mer si
chers collègues la parole est à Monsieur
Colomba vous permettraz un provincial
néanmoins amourux de Paris de mettre son
grain de selle il y a quand même un
paradoxe c'est que l'endroit où se
justifie le plus une
métropole c'est l'endroit où il faudrait
pas la faire c'est quand même un peu
curieux c'est l'endroit où il faudrait
qu'elle soit le plus intégrée au moins
dans certaines de ces parties que on va
sursir encore on devrait sursoir alors
il est vrai que je ne suis pas
particulièrement
enthousiasmé par les propositions qui
nous sont faites et que je pense que sur
la partie la plus hyperurbaine la plus
urbanisée en Contin continu et cetera je
pense plutôt que ce sont les intuitions
de Philippe Dalier qui sont qui sont les
bonnes bien oui ça c'est c'est ce que
c'est ce que je pense mais
franchement euh commencer par dire bon
ben on va voir hein on va se concerter
et il est effectivement un peu peu
déplorable que on nit pas réussi à
progresser depuis donc au minimum on
verra bien ce que la discussion donnera
commençons par délibérer pour voir
comment éventuellement transformer dans
un sens moi qui me paraîtrait plus plus
conforme la le projet initial mais si on
délibère pas si on renvoie encore au
calandre grec où est-ce qu'on va aller
donc il faut
continuer collègue la parole t monsieur
le rapporteur monsieur
dy merci monsieur le Président Mesdames
les ministres chers collègues je
voudrais d'abord rectifier une petite
erreur qu'a fait euh le sédateur
d'allier concernant la création de la
Communauté d'Agglomération clichi
montfermail elle n'a rien à voir avec le
renouvellement urbain puisque elle a été
créée en 2000 1er janvier 2000 donc à
une époque où on parlait pas du tout de
renouvellement urbain si je fais cette
précision c'est pas pour du formalisme
c'est parce que ce qui s'est passé à
Clichy Montfermeil est un des problèmes
de la région Île-de-France et je
voudrais insister là-dessus qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé à cliché monfermeil
c'est qu'il y a deux villes extrêmement
pauvres qui ont chch je dirais pas
désespérément parce qu'il y avait pas de
désespoir il y avait au contraire
beaucoup de volontarisme de s'unir pour
essayer de surmonter effectivement leur
difficultés structurelles et je crois
qu'on est là au cœur du problème et je
crois que je dois être le 10e orateur et
je je suis désolé d'être le premier à en
parler mais ce qui s'est passé dans la
région Île-de-France en TER en terme
d'intercommunalité ce qui les distingue
des autres c'est pas seulement qu'on est
en retard sur le schéma c'est aussi que
ici ou là l'intercommunalité s'est
constitué d'une drôle de façon en gros
pour faire simple les les riches se sont
mariés entre eux dans le plus grand
bonheur et puis obligeant les pauvres à
rester entre eux donc je crois que là il
y a quelque chose qui est extrêmement
choquant c'est extrêmement choquant pour
ce qui nous préoccupe là dans cette loi
c'est-à-dire le logement on l'a vu mais
c'est extrêmement choquant aussi dans le
rayonnement de la région île-de-fance de
la région métropolitaine est-ce que
quelqu'un sur ses bans peut penser une
seconde que cette région va pouvoir
continuer à rayonner à progresser si
elle conserve en son sein des poches
d'extrême pauvreté d'extrême exclusion
c'est impossible donc moi j'entends bien
il faut il faut se donner du temps il
faut réfléchir et cetera enfin un
collègue l'a dit tout à l'heure
parismétropole ça fait des années je dis
bien des années qu'il réfléchissent et
sans rien donner donc je veux bien
admettre que ce qui est proposé ici
n'est pas parfait je le reconnais c'est
pas la première fois et puis ça peut
évoluer
mais quand j'entends remettons ça à plus
tard je je suis extrêmement inquiet
parce que ça fait des années qu'on
discute et on trouve on trouve pas
d'accord bien sûr ça fait pas
l'unanimité ce qu'on propose mais quelle
solution fera l'unanimité moi je suis
très inquiet de revenir à zéro c'està au
statut quo parce que ce que j'ai dénoncé
tout de suite va continuer alors moi je
veux bien je suis je suis adepte oui
mais je je je pense que le sénateur Dali
a effectivement lui au moins une réponse
satisfaisante ça je je le dis mais c'est
pas forcément la seule mais c'est pas la
même chose que de remettre à plus tard
la discussion tout à fait on est
d'accord là-dessus Philippe Dalier mais
moi je veux bien je suis assez partisan
de l'adepte il faut donner du temps au
temps mais quand même pas toujours sinon
si on attend la chose parfaite qui va
faire l'unanimité et bien on va attendre
cette solution là comme au théâtre on
attend Godo c'est-à-dire qu'il n'est
jamais venu merci la parole à Monsieur
le Rapporteur
Germain
mesames les ministres mes chers
collègues est-ce que
finalement le moment n'était pas venu de
traiter cette
question franchement je veux pas ajouter
comment dire aux remarques des des
provinciaux enfin quand même si alors
qu'on fait cette réforme il y a rien qui
est fait pour la région île-de-
France et où est-ce qu'il doit y avoir
une métropole si dans la région
île-de-fance franchement c'est c'est à
n'y rien comprendre et j'entends
et et j'entends et j'entends ce qui est
dit l'amendement de de monsieur daliier
qui a fondé son propos tout à l'heure
donc qui est une alternative au au
disposition du du
gouvernement prévoit en 2020 la création
d'une une collectivité territoriale
nouvelle
fusionnant ce nouveau département avec
les EPC existants en son
sein alors c'est vrai on l'entend ici
faut le reconnaître donc cette réforme
apparaît plus plus audacieuse que que la
proposition qui est faite en ce moment
je dis elle apparaît plus audacieuse
elle règle le problème de la solidarité
entre département au niveau de Paris et
la petite couronne établ l'article 14
mais bien sûr monsieur café mais
toutefois les enjeux
métropolitains se situe surtout au
niveau des compétences des communes et
des agglomérations je le pense monsieur
Dalier plus qu'à celle des départements
et puis votre proposition renvoie
l'organisation de
celle-ci à 2020 sans d'ailleurs prévoir
de généralisation de l'intercommunalité
ni précise
ce que deviennent les compétences de la
ville de
Paris donc votre dispositif je
pense je le juge pas j'entends ce qui se
dit les auditions que nous avons faites
votre votre dispositif à des à des
aspects
entraînants
positifs il peut rassurer les élus de la
grande couronne mais
inquiéter la région et d'autres qui se
sont
manifesté je pense que si le le
Sénat sorait de de ce sujet
simplement en écartant les propositions
du gouvernement et en disant il faut se
donner du temps
euh 10 ans 10 ans
déjà c'est c'est c'est quand même déjà
pas mal comme temps et est-ce qu'on peut
avoir un texte sur la métropole qui
sorte sans aucune proposition concernant
la région
île-de-fance je pense j'en ai discuté
avec d'autres personnes à la fois des
des géographes des des architectes des
aménageurs français et étrangers c'est
c'est l'avantage que permet un réseau
d'ancien
universitaire je pense que il faut
profiter de cette discussion peut-être
pour avoir des propositions qui nous
permettent d'aller plus loin et qui
permettent au au gouvernement de mieux
expliciter ce qu'il voulait
faire je je le pense et
euh
pourquoi ne pas aller vers une
alternative plus volontariste que
l'actuel texte
gouvernemental différente de de votre
proposition monsieur daliier mais qui va
dans son dans son esprit en s'inspirant
du modèle
lyonnais on voit bien que ce qui se
passe dans la région île-de-fance ce qui
se passe dans lag région Île-de-France
c'est qu'il y a une seule ville
métropole moi je l'ai ressenti dans
toutes les
auditions et que on pourrait très bien
créer trois nouvelles collectivités
locales 2015 2016 selon l'article 72 de
la Constitution dans les trois
départements dans les trois départements
de la petite
couronne les départements les
départements prenant les compétences des
communautés d'agglomération parce qu'il
faut pas être que négatif faire des
propositions les départements prenant
les compétences des communautés
d'agglomération avec une large
subsidiarité au niveau
communal et à ce momentlà ces trois
nouvelles collectivités quelques années
plus tard moi j'ai pas de calendrier je
voilà c'est pas à moi de de régler ces
questions ces trois nouvelles
collectivités formeraientent avec Paris
une
métropole selon un modèle voisin du
texte actuel et les agglomérat
les agglomérations de la grande couronne
rejoindrai la métropole sur la base du
volontariat c'est un dispositif
simplifié je crois avec la suppression
des EPCI en petite couronne et la
métropole est plus équilibrée entre ces
quatre composants 2 millions pour Paris
et 1 15 5 millions pour les trois
départements et les élus les élus de la
grande couronne peuvent recomposer leurs
intercommunalités sans obligation et
rest libre d'adhérer à la métropole donc
voilà je veux dire que on peut pas
ressortir je crois de de ce débat en
disant simplement il faut encore prendre
10 ans supplémentaires et je crois que
c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas
contraire à ce que propose le
gouvernement et qui est un petit peu
dans l'esprit de ce que vous avez
proposé monsieur
Dalier parole est à monsieur le
rapporteur
vendong
monsieur le Président madames les
ministres jamais fait mystère à titre
personnel une nette préférence pour
l'orientation donnée depuis longtemps
d'ailleurs par Monsieur Dali encore que
dès qu'on passe à l'acte et qu'on
organise les conditions d'une fusion des
département ça devient beaucoup beaucoup
plus compliqué y compris dans dans les
formations politiques que nous
représentons les uns et les autres
donc
pragmatiquement votre commission des
Lois a fait le choix de
dire et le dernier rapport de la Banque
de France vient lui donner quand même de
l'eau au moulin s'il y a bien un domaine
ou en terme de développement économique
comme en
terme
d'urgence sociale il y a un retard de
l'Île-de-France c'est le
logement je l'ai dit
comparativement au chiffres de la
métropole de Lyon hein si la production
de logement en Île-de-France était
proportionnelle à la production de
logement dans la métropole de Lyon il y
a il se produirait deux fois et demi
plus de logement que ce qui est constaté
et vous voyez
aussi vous voyez aussi en terme
macroéconomique
sur les moyens fonciers chers collègues
voyez aussi l'utilité de rationaliser
les outils fonciers dans le secteur donc
nous nous nous nous avons
trouvé et j'y associe bien volontiers
bien sûr les commissions qui ont
travaillé là-dessus qu'il fallait déjà
simplifier le dispositif et nous sommes
arrivé à à favoriser dans la petite
couronne des intercommunalités sur un
principe
200000 habitants sur cinq communes et
sur la grande couronne et d'ailleurs il
me semble qu'on était assez d'accord en
commission hein d'Alain Richard à
Monsieur yest on a dit ils viennent de
sortir euh d'une
carte intercommunale hein on va pas
leuredemander d'en faire une autre à
partir de là nous pensons que il faut se
mettre en en formation euh pour
reprendre une idée chère au sénateur
café ou à Monsieur kalaltenbach il faut
se remettre dans une formation en disant
l'urgence et le logement et comme
monsieur
carucci je pense que nous avons retiré
du texte en tous les cas en commission
tout ce qui risquait de compromettre cet
objectif prioritaire et comme lui nous
pensons que il y a pas lieu que ce texte
des membres des compétences du conseil
régional le logement on sait bien que le
schéma régional de le d'habitat est une
compétence accrochée au schéma régional
d'aménagement du territoire donc il est
de la région le reste on le confie donc
sur un mode coopératif à cet outil d'un
d'un nouveau genre faut bien le
dire je suis d'accord d'une troème type
mais on a cherché justement à éviter
qu'il
soit un extraterrestre en
sens un syndica mixte qu'on a voulu
ouvert avec voie consultative au
département et à la région et sur
amendement de mon collègue caltenbach
comme on le fera à Lyon et à Marseille
ouvert également à une représentation
d'un collège des maires on aura
l'occasion d'y revenir donc vous voyez
on a pensé que entre ceux qui dorment et
ceux qui rêvent il y avait peut-être une
place pour ceux qui
veillent et on a cherché on a cherché
sur le sur le logement à s'accorder une
priorité absolue de travail ce qui me
personnellement me laisse un goût am mer
c'est qu'on est obligé pour
ça d'arriver à un sadica mixte c'estàd
un niveau
supplémentaire avec un coût de 75
millions d'euros à
l'arrivée voyez voyez que j'essaie
d'équilibré les
préoccupations les préoccupations qui
nous ont tous traversé tous traversé
mais que nous avons choisi de dépasser
considérant que le logement était la
priorité absolue et on s'est réservé
d'ailleurs à 5 ans la possibilité de
refaire un point sur le périmètre des
compétences éventuelles voilà
l'approche pragmatique qu'on a cherché à
avoir madame la ministre vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président de la
Commission messieur le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
sénatrices monsieur le sénateur premier
minist c'est vrai que on ne peut pas je
rejoins ce que disait tout à l'heure la
présidente de la délégation
sortir me semble-il en disant on a une
nouvelle fois reporté j'entends
l'argument
sur l'entrée du fait urbain dans dans le
droit qui est une invation difficile
euh j'entends qu'effectivement on aura
du mal à avoir un consensus général sur
et et facile sur ce que nous proposons
les uns les autres mais même si on
allait sur ce seul point pour répondre à
Monsieur
rafarin c'est vrai que Lyon et Marseille
faisaient partie d'un d'une entité déjà
définie par la loi Paris liyonmseille il
nous semblait extrêmement difficile de
faire avancer les dossiers de Lyon et de
Marseille même si tout ça ne se fera pas
non plus dans une joyeuse bonne humeur
totalement partagée euh sans regarder
Paris l'île-de-fance depuis longtemps un
certain nombre d'élus travaillent sur
une évolution de la gestion de notre
capitale et de Paris capitale dans sa
région souvent vous dites avec juste
raison et Monsieur Karoui défend kuchci
défend bien cette position au fond
pourquoi pas la
région pourquoi pas la région parce que
moi je pense moi qui habite comme vous
dans un territoire où il y a pas de de
métropole que même si on a une hyper
concentration de
population sur sur la question dont on
essaie de trouver solution aujourd'hui
il reste quand même un vaste territoire
euh qui serait quand même me semble-t-il
difficile de gérer par subsidiarité
d'une direction métropolitaine quel
qu'en soit la nature qu'elle soit région
ou pas pe peu importe je j'attache
importance au fait que les grands
territoires ruraux périurbains avec des
petites villes nous sommes tous des
adeptes du polycentrisme vous l'avez
rappelé
soit géré aussi bien que possible et je
pense qu'une
région peut fort
opportunément éviter que j'ai envie de
dire le reste du territoire même s'il
est beaucoup plus grand en surface moins
peuplé de soit soumis à des pressions
foncières à des demandes fortes d'acte
de circulation pour desservir le
territoire plance j'ai je je pense que
la région a tout son sens encore dans
cette dans ce territoire je le pense
aujourd'hui monsieur car je me trompe
peut-être mais faisons attention alors
il y a ceux qui ne veulent pas avancer
du tout et puis ceux qui veulent aller
peut-être très très vite nous nous
avions pris en compte et nous avons pris
en compte le fait que en 2010
effectivement du temps a été donné par
sagesse d'après les débats à la petite
couronne pour ne pas rentrer dans
l'intercommunalité pour qu'elle ait le
temps pour que l'ensemble des élus de la
Petite Couronne a le temps de se poser à
la fois donc ça fait maintenant presque
3 ans disons 2 ans de travail de se
poser à la fois la question de
l'intercommunalité et d'une métropole
par fusion subsidiarité absorption peu
importe mais le temps avait été donné le
temps est passé et si nous sortions du
Sénat sans monter aucune marche sans
ouvrir la porte d'une meilleure
gouvernance de cet ensemble même si et
les autres font bien leur travail
attention à ne pas non plus fustiger et
bien je pense que nous aurions grande
responsabilité parce que quand quand y
aura-t-il quand quand viendra un autre
texte après
2017 en 2020 je ne sais pas donc on a
quand même aussi à poser les bases du de
cette
urgence que la petite couronne fasse le
travail de l'intercommunité me semble
juste parce que l'ensemble des
territoires de France l'ont fait avecé
et nous nous avons suivi cette logique
de la loi de 2010 même si c'était
difficile parce que elle avait du sens
et en prenant en compte l'amendement
péissar c'est dire l'année de plus nous
avons fait conduire par l'ensemble des
représentants de l'État le travail
commenca continuité républicaine était
de qualité j'espère et ça pas été sans
grandes difficultés les uns ou les
autres s'en souviennent donc moi il me
semble déjà que le minimum c'est que la
première couronne réponde au même
impératif qu'il y ait souci au-delà sur
ceux qui ont déjà travaillé le
l'intercommunalité je pense qu'on peut
tous l'entendre qu'on peut très bien
trouver une solution pour éviter de
remettre le chantier ce qui vient de de
se terminer mais qu'il y ait ce souci
n'empêche pas qu'il faut que les
intercommunalités aent un minimum de
surface qu'on sorte de ces deux communes
ici ou là obligé de vivre ensemble ou
vivant ensemble avec enthousiasme une
élu de cette région me disait samedi
après-midi que le grand souci parfois
c'est de savoir comment on peut dépenser
son son argent
entre soi trouver les bonnes solutions
parce que les communes se portent très
très très bien ell se es se portent très
bien grâce à la France entière parce que
ce sont souvent des ressources li à des
sièges sociaux avec des unités de
production qui sont sur la France
entière donc nous sommes tous attentifs
à ce que tout ça fonctionne bien donc
première couronne ça nous semble
indispensable je ne vois pas comment le
gouvernement soutiendrait l'abandon de
de ce projet ensuite sur la 2è 3e on est
prêt à tout
entendre autre aspect très important
pour nous est les uns et les autres le
rappeler c'est le
logement on ne peut pas
continuer comme cela et je disais des
élus de l'île-de-fance et qui me disait
vous vous vous nous jugez mal non on ne
juge pas mal l'île-de-fance mais c'est
vrai que la France entière est
intéressée à ce
que c problème du logement fonctionne
mieux comme celui de transport pourquoi
parce que la grande grande majorité des
familles de la France
entiers ont ici ou là quelqu'un qui vit
et qui vit dans des conditions un peu
complexes donc c'est vrai que le
logement nous semble indispensable à
tous élu de tous les territoires
métropolitains et d'R M 2ème point 3ème
point le temps Paris Métropole a
beaucoup travaillé et même s'il n'y a
pas eu et on le regrette tous un
accord unanime porté devant le Premier
ministre au mois de décembre dernier le
travail a continué il faut saluer à la
fois le livre blanc et le Livre vert
c'est dire cette volonté d'aller à la
rencontre des populations je pense que
l'ensemble des élus qui ont participé à
ce travail mérite un coup de chapeau sur
l'engagement
chronophage et qu'ils ont pris mais ils
l'ont fait avec enthousiasme et que dit
aujourd'hui cette
association
ce C ce
syndicat
mixte que que dit-il je je vais pas vous
donner ses conclusions mais ces
interrogations sa première interrogation
c'est qu'effectivement ils ont créé ce
syndicat pour pouvoir sortir sur un
schéma
métropolitain et que l'objet objectif
n'était pas de gérer des petits
problèmes ou des gros problèmes de
proximité mais de sortir sur un schéma
métropolitain et que Grand Paris
Métropole pour eux c'est un objectif
même s'ils se sont pas mis d'accord à
l'heure où je vous parle il se revoit
encore demain saiton jamais sur un un un
territoire ils ont tenu à souligner ça
rejoint les propos de des un et des
autres le caractère polycentrique de
Grand-Paris métropole et de cette
approche par rapport à la dynamique des
territoires et au fond l'idée que les
intercommunités pouvaient se rapprocher
de la logique des CDT je pense que c'est
pas quelque chose de
totalement inefficace qu'effectivement
la logique des CDT peut
poser non pas exemple mais au moins
proposition pour la logique de l'interco
nouvelle ils ont tous souligné la
nécessité de terminer les projets
intercommunaux là-dessus on est d'accord
même si tout le monde n'est pas d'accord
sur le nombre de communes je reviendrai
ils ont insisté ça rejoint des
préoccupation exprimée lors de la
discussion générale surtout la place des
communes doit être réaffirmée avec le
rôle des maires et plus on avance vers
la métropole et meilleur sera leur
semble-t-il le rôle des maires dans la
gestion de de leur communes c'est
exactement non je je je ne dis pas ce
que je dis moi
je je je dis ce que m'ont remis comme
document non mais c'est un document
qu'ils ont qu'ils m'ont remis
donc non non non ils ont espéré alors je
vais changer les mots ils ont espéré une
affiration du rôle des maires et ensuite
effectivement vous étiez présents à la
réunion hein que nous avons tenu à
Matignon ils n'ont pas su dire s'il
fallait une première
couronne prendre l'unité urbaine
Inc s'il fallait
ensuite donner plus de compéten à cette
terre urbaine il s'est
organisé et là les choses se sont
arrêtées dans le travail de
préfiguration je pense qu'on ils l'ont
tous regret vous aussi donc moi ce que
je pense aujourd'hui c'est qu'il faut
ce qui a été dit par la commission des
lois par la commission d'aménagement
héritable développement durable aussi
qui s'est exprimé là-dessus faire monter
une première marche ch de
l'intercommunaité me semble importante
avoir une gouvernance de la zone danse
nous semble importante pour le logement
confirmer la région dans son rôle
concernant les transports là au moins
j'ai l'impression monsieur qu'il a un
semblant
d'accord confirme mais la région et même
renforcé la compétence qu'elle n'a pas
aujourd'hui sur l'habitat elle ne l'a
pas elle n'a compétence qu'en terme de
schéma régional d'aménagement du
territoire comme toutes les régions de
France ajouter un schéma régional de
l'habitat pour répondre à la l'anxiété
je dis bien l'anxiété des régions les
plus excentrées par rapport à la
pression foncière et à ce qui pourrait
se produire c'est ce que nous disent les
élus de cette couronne la plus éloignée
du centre et si on peut confirmer la
région dans ce avec cette compétence
donner une compétence opérationnelle sur
le logement à cette entité zone d'se moi
je pense qu'entre les deux lectures
parce qu'on va pas sortir a quelque
chose de parfait de cette première
lecture je pense qu' entre les deux
lectures il faudra réunir à nouveau la
Commission et et la commission
d'aménagement les deux commissions
peut-être réunies pour voir comment se
rapprochent les points de vue parce que
j'ai été très sensible à la différence
exprimée entre les deux commissions et
enfin et j'en terminerai là je
m'exprimerai peu sur les amendements
j'ai entendu aussi qu'il faut s'occuper
du financement mais qu'il faut à la fois
définir une est pure mais aller jusqu'au
PLF pour la négociation de ce
financement solidaire indispensable mais
que vous avez dans votre commission des
finances et votre commission des Lois
exprimé trop tôt
euh enveloppé j'ai envie de dire donc
moi sur l'idée de porter le montant au
PLF me semble une bonne idée voilà les
premiers points que je voulais dire
souligner que c'est qu' c'est c'est
difficile d'entendre que ces élus qui
ont tant travaillé dans dans Paris
Métropole n'ont rien fait de correct je
je pense qu'ils ont fait avancer l'idée
et qu'il faut quand même leur rendre
hommage sur tout le travail qu'ils ont
fait toute tendance politique confondue
et les encourager en faisant au moins un
pas au cours de la première
lecture merci madame la
ministre
trois amendements identiques de
suppression font l'objet d'une
discussion commune l'amendement 23
rectifié quatire présenté par Monsieur
CCI monsieur le Président Mesdames les
ministres madame le
ministre je je vais vous dire le le
sentiment profond qui est le nôtre c'est
que on est bien conscient en île- de
France ne croyez pas que la la structure
actuelle ne marche pas ou plus
exactement qu'il y a des choses qui
marchent les communes ont mis en place
des syndicats sur un certain nombre de
sujets et ça marche bien je veux pas
qu'on dise qu'en île-de-fance les élus
sont tellement repliés sur eux-mêmes
qu'ils ne progressent pas ça n'est pas
vrai parce qu'ils répondent aux besoins
des populations comme tous les élus sur
l'ensemble du territoire
national le vrai problème c'est que vous
le dites et j'en suis bien conscient au
sein de Paris Métropole comme dans
d'utres structure on n'est pas arrivé à
se mettre d'accord pourquoi parce qu'on
a un vrai sujet on a pratiquement 19 %
de la population nationale sur 2 % du
territoire national et par conséquent
quand vous dites une métropole pourquoi
pas mais pas une métropole qui fait 10
millions d'habitants sur 12 millions
parce qu'en réalité à la fois vous tuez
les marges de notre région ne vous
faites pas d'illusion quand vous dites
la région s'en occupera mais la région
dessaisie du logement parce qu'en
réalité elle est dessaisie du logement
qu'est-ce que vous voulez qu'elle fasse
quand on va lui dire il faut trouver des
moyens de faire de construire à Harpagon
quand on va lui dire bah vous avez la
capacité la compétence transport mais
vous n'avez pas celle du logement il y a
des logiques quand même et je demande à
tous les élus de province comme de
l'Île-de-France de penser que la logique
c'est que le logement et les transports
soient de compétenence sur la même
autorité enfin comment voulez-vous qu'on
fasse on se plaint tous qu'en région
Île-de France le transport ne marche pas
que et pourtant fait des efforts
considérables au niveau financier et
malgré ça on y'y arrive pas Si vous ne
rejoignez pas ces deux compétences on y
arrivera pas alors est-ce qu'il faut que
la métropole soit la région peut-être
sans doute est-ce qu'il faut une
métropole plus petite tenant en compte
des structures comme le propose philippe
Dallier peut-être sans doute mais en
tout cas le système qui consiste à dire
on laisse tout ce qui existe et on
rajoute une strate et cette strate on
lui donne le logement mais on lui donne
pas les transports et on fait en sorte
en plus que dans toutes les communes en
petite et en moyenne couronne on va
imposer des EPCI qui ne sont ou pas
souhaités ou en tout cas pas ceux qui
existent et à ceux qui existent on va
leur dire prière de disparaître pour en
faire d'autres franchement c'est le
monde à l'envers pourquoi veut-on ici
dans la Haute Assemblée mettre en en
colère parce que ce sera de la colère
les élus d'île-de-fance qui ne méritent
ni protection particulière mais ni blâ
particulier parce qu'ils font leur
travail et c'est franchement on a
l'impression d'un texte forcé contrain
pour dire aux élus vous n'avez pas fait
votre job et ben comme vous n'êtes pas
bon on va décider à votre place et
sincèrement madame la la ministre
sincèrement vous diriez et moi je suis
prêt et beaucoup ici sont prêts vous
diriez on va faire des États généraux
d'Île- de France et on veut une solution
dans les 6 mois et c'est comme ça et on
discute et on trouve une solution sur la
métropole qui sera peut-être la solution
d'allier même moi je suis pas avancer
mais aujourd'hui venir et dire aux élus
c'est comme ça des EPCI à 200000 les uns
le logement les autres les transport ça
ne marchera pas vous pouvez faire voter
ce texte à l'Assemblée nationale parce
que naturellement vous aurez la majorité
mais sincèrement vous aurez contre vous
la grande majorité toute couleur
politique confondu des élus
d'île-de-fance qui ne mérite pas
ça 230 rectifi la parole à Monsieur
Dalier merci monsieur le Président
Madame ministre mes chers collègues je
crois qu'il y a pas plus grand défenseur
d'une vraie métropole parisienne que moi
dans cet hémicycle pas le seul mais en
tous les cas j'y ai réfléchi depuis
longtemps et ce que vous nous proposez
que vous nous présentez comme un premier
pas madame la ministre c'est absolument
dramatique parce que c'est le contraire
de la méro po intégré le contraire et si
vous nous imposez de rentrer en interco
par plaque de 2 ou 300000 en petite
couronne on en prend pour 15 à 20 ans
madame la ministre 15 à 20 ans et il y
aura jamais de métropole intégrée et
Messieurs les rapporteurs ce que vous
oubliez de rappeler quand même c'est que
le partage de la richesse économique qui
se fait sur la base de l'interco et
est-ce que ça va être ça la métropole
solidaire de couper la SC saint en 4 ou
en 5 les hautes scèes en 4 ou en 5 le
valdemarne en 4 ou en 5 c'est ça le bon
périmètre de partage de la richesse
fiscale c'est cela le bon périmètre pour
jauger de la mixité sociale vous allez
demander des PLU et des PLH à cette
échelle- là mais est-ce que vous vous
rendez compte de ce que vous êtes en
train de nous dire il faut aller vers la
métropole intégrée alors effectivement
c'est peut-être la la première couronne
parce que je trouvais que c'était plus
simple c'est peut-être plus large mais
en tous les cas ça ne peut pas être le
découpage en tranche de la SA sa du
veldemard des des hautes scènes quand
vous l'aurez fait on en prend pour 15
ans ou 20 ans donc vous proposez qu'
étant un premier pas ça va tuer l'idée
même de la métropole pour 15 ou 20 ans
et on a déjà 40 ans de retard sur les
communauté urbaine en province est-ce
qu'on peut faire ça et quand certains
disaient que je suis le seul dépenseur
de ce modèle mais moi je cite Claude
Bartolone président de l'Assemblée
nationale qui s'est prononcé il y a un
an pour un modèle comme celui que je
propose aujourd'hui il faut aller vers
ça et pourquoi on y va pas et pourquoi
ça discute tant dans Paris Métropole
parce que tous ceux qui devraient a
lâcher un peu d'argent ou un peu de
pouvoir et qui ne le veulent pas et bien
se satisfont de cette de de ce que vous
nous proposez allez hop une couche de
plus dans le 1000feuille une couche de
plus dans le mil000feuille comme s'il y
en avait pas déjà assez et quand n vous
nous dites quelqu'un a dit dans le débat
mais on va s'appuyer sur les communes de
la première couronne mais enfin écoutez
eau électricité gaz ordure ménagère les
grands syndicats technique ça existe
déjà qu'est-ce qui va rester à mettre en
commun et qu'est-ce que vont conserver
des communes de 40 60 100000 habitants
le CCAS à caractère communautaire on va
s'occuper de la voirie à caractère
communautaire dans un espace qui fait 7
millions d'habitants mais est-ce que
vous vous rendez compte de ce que vous
nous dites c'est l'antimétropole que
vous êtes en train de construire et tout
cela parce que c'est difficile et parce
qu'il faut faire de la peine à certains
à droite et à gauche mais il est temps
de faire de la peine à certains parce
que c'est l'intérêt national de
construire ce Grand Paris et on pourra
le faire qu'en construisant une
métropole intégrée sur sur un sur un
périmètre ou sur un autre discutons de
cela mais le saucissonnage de la petite
couronne c'est vraiment la pire des
solutions on en prend pour 20 ans merci
chers collègues l'amendement 447 est
présenté par Monsieur
Favier madame la ministre monsieur le
Président mes chers collègues si dans la
loi de 2010 sur la base d'un amendement
de notre collègue daller les
départements de la petite couronne
n'avaient pas été contraint à mettre en
place l'achèvement de leur
intercommunalité nous l'avons rappelé
c'était du fait de l'objectif affiché
alors de créer donc une grande
communauté urbaine à l'échelle de Paris
et des hautes scènes du valdeemarne et
de la sane saintis et aussi donc en
conséquence la création d'Interco sur
tout leur territoire risquait donc de
devenir des obstacles donc à ce projet
aujourd'hui le texte qui nous est
présenté créant donc une métropole
parisienne fondée sur des
intercommunalités de grande taille il
est donc devenu nécessaire pour ceux qui
ont cette ambition de mettre en place
donc les procédures nécessaires à
l'achèvement autoritaire de la carte
intercommunale dans ces trois
départements et malheureusement je vois
bien le regretter sans prendre en compte
le travail qui est actuellement en cours
parce que contrairement à ce qui a été
dit il y a eu du retard sans doute en
Île-de-France mais aujourd'hui beaucoup
de choses ont évolué dans la dernière
période et notamment à travers à partir
des réflexions qui ont été conduites sur
autour des réseaux de transport et de
l'aménagement urbain lié à ces réseaux
de transport et la situation n'est donc
pas figée euh dès 2010 et pour toute la
France nous étions contre ces procédures
contraignantes et c'est donc en pleine
cohérence que donc nous demandons la
suppression de cet article nous ne
sommes d'autant plus que pour ces trois
départements que les arguments utilisé
en 2010 pour justifier ces mesures ne
trouve pas de justification ici en effet
la vision de rassembler des communes
autour de leur ville centre ou à partir
de bassin de vie on le sait plus
complexe dans ces trois départements et
on on on l'a déjà je me suis déjà
exprimé sur ce point de plus les
communes de ces départements sont pour
la plupart d'entre elles d'une taille
qu'ell dispose déjà de services
municipaux souvent très structurés dans
de nombreux domaines d'intervention pour
autant des coopérations se sont déjà
mises en place depuis nombreuses années
sur la base du volontariat et ça a été
rappelé dans des syndicats
intercommunaux et même parfois
interdépartementaux dans des domaines
essentiels comme l'électricité les
réseaux de télécommunication le
traitement des déchets la lutte contre
les inondations l'assaainissement le
traitement des eaux usées ou les
questions de restauration collective et
toutes ces structures aujourd'hui
fonctionnent et fonctionnent plutôt bien
donc ne serait-il pas plus judicieux de
chercher au contraire à les élargir et à
les renforcer plutôt qu'aujourd'hui à
les déstabiliser en tout cas une chose
est sûre ce n'est pas en les morcelans
que nous irons de l'avant et ce serait
au contraire je pense une marche arrière
incompréhensible enfin dans ces trois
départements de nombreuses
intercommunalités sont déjà en place or
la vision portée par ce texte va en
détruire un certain nombre car elle
n'atignent pas donc les seuils recis
notamment ce seuil de 300000 habitants
aussi dans ces conditions i vous
comprendrez que nous puissions que
demander la suppression de cet article
sans compter évidemment ceux qui sont
liés par les procédures envisagé et qui
donne d'ailleurs trop de pouvoir je
pense au préfet pour permettre de passer
outre parfois à la vie des communes
elles-même je pense qu'au stade où nous
sommes et compte tenu du travail déjà
engagé d'ailleurs par le syndicat mixte
Paris Métropole auquel plus de 200
collectivités adhér je partage pas
l'idée qu' ne s'est rien passé depuis la
création de ce syndicat métropole je
suis assez surpris qu'on puisse sur ces
bans enfin sur certains de ces bans le
dire sachant qui était à l'initiative
effectivement le maire de Paris qui est
à l'initiative de de cette de cette
structure nous avons travail il y a eu
beaucoup de travail de fait et notamment
des questions importantes ont
pu prospérer je pense sur notamment sur
les questions financières et la la la
sur des les
péréquations intercommunales en
Île-de-France c'est des propositions qui
ont été travaillées par le Sicat mix
Paris métropoleè demandé de conclure
s'il vous plaît et donc je pense que au
stade où nous sommes je pense qu'il
faudrait effectivement se tourner plutôt
vers le syndicat mix Paris Métropole
pour continuer de travailler sur des
propositions et pourquoi pas vers un
projet de loi spécifique à Paris qui
nous permettrait donc de travailler dans
la sérénité puisqu'on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui le consensus n'est pas
établi sur les propositions qui nous
sont
faites merci monsieur le rapporteur quel
est l'avis de la commission sur les
amendements j'ai expliqué tout à l'heure
le pragmatisme qui avait conduit la
commission des lois à chercher un
système assoupli et à pas renoncer à
cette absolue priorité qu euh la mise en
œuvre d'un plan local de l'habitat qui
aurait d'ailleurs un caractère
prescriptif et qui pourrait aller avec
d'une formule coopérativ et des
véritables opérations d'aménagement à
mutualiser donc j'ai metis donc un avis
défavorable à l'amendement de
suppression merci Monsieur rapporteur
madame la ministre avis défavorable pour
explication de vote madame de
BR merci monsieur le Président Madame le
ministre mes chers collègues je voudrais
juste prendre la parole 30 secondes pour
expliquer et répondre aussi à Madame
gourau et à d'autres et j'entends que en
île-de-fance certains élus ne feraient
pas suffisamment d'effort pour
s'organiser en inter je voudrais donner
l'exemple de mon
intercommunalité intercommunalité c'est
Grand Paris sa-ouest je parle aussi sous
le contrôle d' RV Marseille 300000
habitants 9e intercommunalité de France
donc pourquoi je voterai contre
l'article contre le pardon le
l'amendement pour l'amendement pardon de
Roger carucci tout simplement parce que
vous créez une obligation au lieu de
donner un petit peu de temps au temps
aux élus je pense que les élus sont des
élus responsables qui soit Paris qui
soit qui soit de Marseille Lyon nous
pouvons nous organiser mais nous n
refusons cette obligation et nous
refusons le fait qu'il y ait une strate
supplémentaire qui soit créée avec en
plus des compéten vers une entité le
logement vers une entité les transports
vers une autre entité or on sait très
bien qu'il faudrait que les deux soit
elles sont liées il faut que l'autorité
soi la même donc tout ça est fait dans
le désordre tout ça est fait dans la
précipitation et c'est pourquoi je
voterai cet amendement suppression merci
ch collègue la parole à Monsieur pour
explication de vote
oui monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre mes chers collègues c'est vrai
que on le sent dans le débat là les
choses ne sont malheureusement pas
mû je je pense que il y a eu des
propositions qui ont été faites tout à
l'heure par notre collègue Germain et
qui pourrait être des propositions que
l'on pourrait suivre en tout cas il n'y
a pas eu à un moment
donné de date donnée ou de
de période de concertation qui soit
définie pour définir un projet pour
cette région Île-de-France alors bien
sûr que ici où là à Paris Métropole
ailleurs on y a réfléchi mais moi je
pense qu'il y a besoin de se donner un
délai et de donner aux élus de cette
région un délai qui leur permette de
définir l'architecture de gouvernance de
la région et d'où découlera la taille
des intercommunalités si il y a des
intercommunalités parce que jean-germain
proposait que on on fusionne quoi on
donne les intercot dans les départements
et qu'on donne les en tout cas sur la
petite couronne parce que la grande
couronne on en parle pas tant que ça
j'ai l'impression que dans dans
l'hémicycle ici on parle beaucoup de la
petite couronne et de Paris mais que la
grande couronne intéresse un petit peu
moins moi je pense qu'il faut il faut
pas s'en désintéresser de la grande
couronne et la grande couronne compte et
que même les secteurs ruraux de
l'Île-de-France compent aussi parce
qu'on a aussi nos secteurs ruraux et
qu'il faut pas oublier
donc je pense que ça mérite le sujet
mérite que on s'y penche sérieusement
avec un délai donné il s'agit pas de
donner du temps il s'agit pas de se dire
on par dans 10 ans il s'agit de se dire
on part pour 6 mois voilà et ce qu' ce
ce qu'a dit Roger carucci moi j'avais
dit 1 an tout à l'heure mais on peut
dire 6 mois on se donne 6 mois et on y
va et on on travaille on travaille
ensemble on essaie d'aboutir à à une
solution qui nous paraisse euh partagée
et positive pour l'Île-de-France alors
que là certains nous disent on fait
preuve de pragmatisme on rajoute une
structure comme on a toujours fait
finalement on a un problème on rajoute
une structure supplémentaire un syndicat
mixte et allons-y on est parti ça ne
réglera pas le problème mes chers
collègues du logement en Île-de-France
je ne suis sûr que ça ne le règlera pas
on aura beau euh se faire plaisir se
dire des des choses ici agréables sur le
logement mais ça ne le règlera
absolument pas donc je je pense que il y
a d'autres disposition à prendre pour
essayer d'améliorer le fonctionnement de
notre région et donc la production de
logement qui est indispensable dans
notre région on est d'accord pour le
faire je je vois pas pourquoi on va euh
vouloir se précipiter à fixer comme on
le fait là euh des des un nombre de
personnes pour des intercommunalités ce
qui pour moi n'a aucun sens aujourd'hui
donc donnons-nous du temps moi je suis
je suis contre cet article alors avec
les collègues du groupe c'est vrai que
on a une discussion puisque il y a des
amendements que l'on souhaite pouvoir
défendre et que si on vote l'amendement
de suppression on ne peut plus discuter
des des amendements 10 d'amélioration
moi je pense que il sera difficile
d'améliorer cet article puisque il vient
en premier alors que en fait il faudrait
qu'on soit d'accord déjà sur
l'architecture globale ce que l'on n'est
pas pour pouvoir voter donc moi je
propose en tout cas pour ma part je je
vais m'abstenir sur cet amendement mais
je voterai contre l'article c'estàd que
je je laisse je laisse un petit peu la
discussion se dérouler je souhaite que
cette discussion se déroule on nait pas
eu la chance de l'avoir pour la deuxème
partie du budget sur le le PLF mais je
je souhaite que le Sénat non c'est pas
de la mienne non plus mais mais je
souhaite que le Sénat euh en tout cas se
donne la possibilité de discuter sur cet
article que l'on voit par rapport aux
amendements quelle est la position
quelles sont les évolutions mais s'il y
a pas d'évolution en tout cas pour ma
part je voterai contre l'article 10
merci chers collègu la parole est à
Monsieur kalttenbach pour explication de
vote monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre chers collègues bien évidemment
je voterai contre cet amendement de
suppression qui je le rappelle concerne
un article qui ne vise qu'à terminer la
carte de l'intercommunalité dans les
trois départements de la petite couronne
partout en France il y a maintenant une
carte de l'intercommunalité reste trois
départements en petite couronne et dans
certains secteurs de ces département il
n'y a pas encore d'intercommunalité
j'ajoute comme l'a dit le rapporteur
dyain que certaines intercommunalités en
petite couronne sont particulièrement
aberrentes il a cité cliché sousbois
Montfermeil c'est vrai
marié de fites de communes avec peu de
moyens n'est pas forcément le mariage le
plus heureux même si ça permet toujours
d'avancer mais j'ai d'autres exemple
dans mon département les haut scenes où
il y a une intercommunalité entre puto
et courbeevie de villes qui sont loin
d'être dans le besoin assis sur un tas
d'or et qui ne se sont mariés que pour
continuer à protéger leur coffre fort
j'ai un autre exemple où nous avons une
particularité toujours dans les hautes
scènes mais les hautes scènes sont
particulièrement prolixes pour ce type
de Cré activité nous avons une
intercomnauté avec deux communes
Châtillon montrrouge qui n'est pas une
communauté d'agglomération mais une
communauté de communes ils ont pris un
un schéma adapté au monde rural pour se
protéger en fait parce que ils se
sentent un peu pris en étau par des
communes qui n'ont pas la même couleur
politique et donc pour se protéger ils
ont à minima fait une communaé de
commune tout ça est ridicule il faut
avancer nous avons eu 3 ans pour
réfléchir
créer déjà de nombreuses
intercomunalités en petite couronne qui
fonctionne bien ça a été dit pour Grand
Paris saouest c'est le cas pour
l'agglomération que j'ai créé avec sud
de scè c'est vrai pour rest ensemble
donc il y a des exemples qui montrent
que l'intercommunalité en petite
couronne fonctionne malheureusement
certains ne veulent pas avancer certains
font de la résistance comme au début
d'ailleurs partout en France et c'est
pourquoi il a fallu à un moment ou un
autre mettre une barre et permettre ces
regroupements à une taille suffisante le
gouvernement avait avancé 300000 j'ai
défendu en commission des lois un
amendement à 200000 parce que ça me
semble plus raisonnable en petite
couronne ou ou mais ouis c'est vous êtes
parfait mais bon laissez laissez chacun
laissz chacun avoir des tailles adaptées
parce que et on le voit il y a ce seuil
de population mais étant un praticien un
modeste praticien je suis m d'une
commune de 50000 et président d'un aglo
de 150000 on voit que le plus compliqué
c'est pas tant la taille de
l'intercommunalité que le nombre de
communes parce que nous avons souvent
des agglomérations où les communes ont
transféré des services de proximités les
conservatoires les piscines les théâtres
chaque commune a tous ses équipements
ils ont été transférés à une taille
raisonnable en nombre de villes c'est
gérable mais si on arrive à des
intercommunalités qui vont compter 12 13
14 villes on aura beaucoup de mal à
maintenir cette proximité c'est pourquoi
moi je reste attaché en petite couronne
à ce qu'il y ait quand même des
intercommunalités qui permettent en lien
avec les villes de gérer ces services de
proximité c'est ce que Paris Métropole
appelle les coopératives de communes et
c'est je crois une très bonne chose qui
permet d'avoir de la cohérence de la
solidarité mais également de la
proximité mais qu'ensuite et je ne veux
pas évacuer le débat qui va rebondir à
travers les articles qui vont suivre il
faut un schéma cohérent pour la
métropole aujourd'hui c'est une première
étape bien évidemment ce n'est qu'une
première étape il faudra très vite aller
plus loin
faudra-t-il intégrer complètement les
trois départements de la petite couronne
et les fondre dans la métropole
faudra-t-il aller jusqu'à la région j'en
doute un peu mais la réflexion pourra
être lancée mais quoi qu'il en soit
commençons par passer des étapes la
première étape qui est proposée c'est
déjà de terminer la carte de
l'intercommunalité en petite couronne
avec une taille qui a 200000 me semble
raisonnable en portant à 5 le nombre de
commune là aussi on arrive à avoir une
cohérence et des équilibres qui nous
permettront de continuer à avancer mais
à force de dire attendons pour faire
bien mieux demain on finit par ne rien
faire et alors que même même dans la
France même dans la France rurale où il
y avait énormément de réticence à
l'intercommunalité où les villages ne
pouvaient pas se marier et on avait une
guerre des clochers qui s'annonçait on a
vu que rapidement cette carte elle a pu
se faire dans toute la France arrêtons
cette spécificité qui n'a aucun sens
terminons la carte en petite couronne et
on pourra passer à l'étape supérieure
qui est l'indispensable métropole et
là-dessus bien sûr il faudra que le
débat se poursuive puisque là nous
n'avons qu'une première étape mais voilà
commençons par cette première marche qui
est indispensable et ne cherchons pas de
faux fuyant on a eu assez de temps pour
travailler ceux qui ont voulu travailler
on travailler bah ceux qui ne veulent
pas travailler il fautir les pousser un
petit peu pour qu'ils avance merci chers
collègues la parole est à Monsieur café
pour explication de vote merci Monsieur
le le président très rapidement puisque
je me suis déjà exprimé sur cette
question la première chose que je
voudrais faire c'est rendre hommage aux
deux ministres qui sont parmi nous parce
que elles ont une tâche extrêmement
difficile sur ce texte je voudrais les
remercier en fait de la manière dont
elles abordent la discussion euh de la
conviction avec laquelle elles le font
euh de leur qualité d'écoute euh et
également de la manière dont elles
prennent ce sujet sur le Grand Paris euh
je tenais à le dire c'est la première
chose la deuxième chose euh c'est que
écoutez
euh je veux bien tout ce qu'on veut
je veux bien qu'on se donne 3 mois qu'on
se donne 6 mois pour discuter et trouver
une solution mais enfin je constate
simplement que la conférence
métropolitaine a été créée si ma mémoire
est bonne en 2006 2007 Paris Métropole a
été créé si ma mémoire est bonne en 2008
200009 dans les statutes de Paris
Métropole cher Christian Favier il me
semble que l'un des trois principaux
points des statutes de Paris Métropole
c'est de proposer une ution sur sur la
gouvernance où en sommes-nous après 5 6
ans de discussion et ce n'est pas faire
insulte chchristian Favier encore une
fois à Paris Métropole je constate
simplement qu'au bout de 5 ou 6 ans et
bien il n'y a aucune solution aucune
solution qui fasse à minima consensus à
minima entre les élus locaux donc je
trouve si vous voulez que la véhémence
de certains
propos à à à ce quiesprit les deux
ministres est totalement
effondé ce projet de loi d'une certaine
manière en fait n'est que le reflet de
l'indécision et de l'incapacité des élus
locaux franciliens à proposer une
solution au gouvernement reconnaissonsle
alors moi je veux bien 6 mois de plus
enfin qu'amèneront 6 mois de plus car
regardons les amendements qui viendront
dans dans la discussion par la suite il
y a ceux qui sont pour la fusion des
trois départements il y a ceux qui sont
pour la M
sur la petite couronne il y a ceux qui
sont pour une métropole sur un périmètre
plus large il y a ceux qui sont pour la
métropole sur la région il y a ceux qui
sont sur pour une autorité organisatrice
du logement parfois ce sont les mêmes
d'ailleurs qui sont pour toutes ces
solution et vous croyez qu'en 6 mois
nous allons trouver la solution entre
nous la pierre philosophale que nous
allons proposer au gouvernement qui la
traduira dans un texte de loif enfin
écoutez madame la ministre bon ce serait
un rêve bon et très franchement cont
tenu d'un certain nombre si vous voulez
de de
de de problèmes extrêmement graves
auquels nous sommes confrontés je ne
veux pas m'engager dans cette solution
du rêve dont nous savons bien que nous
ne la trouverons pas voilà quelque soit
d'ailleurs le fondateur de Paris
Métropole monsieur Favier car j'ai ma
liberté de parole voilà
les 200000 et bien écoutez parlons-en
donc que propose ce que propose ce
texte de réaliser une avancée et qui
n'est pas attentatoire aux collectivités
locales monsieur Dallier puisqu'il ne
s'agit en réalité regardez le texte que
d'un pôle métropolitain coopératif entre
intercommunalité de manière à pouvoir
avancer sur le sujet majeur qui reste en
île-defance et qui nous faut résoudre à
savoir celui du logement j'ai parlé tout
à l'heure de problèmes structurant sur
l'iste de France et bien d'une certaine
manière ce texte et les autres textes
qui viendront nous permettront d'avancer
nous avons des problèmes de gouvernance
en terme de développement économique et
d'emploi et bien le texte à venir qui
confiera à la région des compétences
accrues en matière de développement
économique et d'emploi sera le bienvenu
ce texte là d'une certaine manière en
matière de transport en réglant
l'articulation entre la NGP qui
heureusement n'est pas supprimé et le
STIF constitue un progrès en matière de
gouvernance il nous reste cette question
du logement
l'ancinante enfin nous savons tous ici
que nous construisons en île-de-fance
35000 logements 40000 au maximum par an
alors que la loi de 2010 celle de celle
du Grand Paris estime que que c'est
70000 qu'il faut en construire est-ce
que nous avançons sur cette question je
ne prétends pas que le gouvernement nous
propose la pierre philosophale je dis
simplement qu'il nous propose un
instrument qui nous permet d'avancer
dans un sens qui n'est pas attentatoire
aux collectivités territoriales et c'est
la raison pour laquelle je ne voterai
pas cet amendement de suppression merci
chers collègues la parole est à Monsieur
capouanella pour explication de
vote merci monsieur le président madames
les ministres mes chers collègues
premier point d'abord je j'ai un peu le
sentiment que nous sommes en train de
confondre ou d'additionner deux débats
on viendra après sur les articles
concernant la métropole on est d'abord
là sur un article qui est sur
l'achèvement de l'intercommunalité alors
évidemment les deux sont liés parce que
il faudra d'abord faire
l'intercommunalité avant de faire la
métropole et je d'Ille un amendement sur
ce point-là mais il me semble que on
peut pas refuser de faire
l'intercommunalité en première couronne
parce qu'elle se bâtit jusque là parce
que certains s'y sont mis et que ça
serait quelque part les pénaliser que de
pas veiller à ce que l'ensemble de la
carte se fasse moi je suis pour une tèse
claire j'aurais bien aimé d'ailleurs y
avoir pensé avant parce que j'ai pensé
10 minutes après le début de cette
séance c'était un amendement clair pour
simplement dire que l'Île-de-France la
première couronne rentre dans le droit
commun et que elle a l'obligation de
faire l'intercommunalité comme partout
en France point sans clause de taille et
l'erreur me semble-t-il majeure c'est
donner une toise à 200 ou à 300000 qui
est vécu par tous les élus comme une
confiscation comme une perte de
démocratie comme une perte de proximité
c'est ça le problème donc je pense que
la position de consensus ça serait ça ça
serait de dire on fait sortir
l'île-de-fance de cette de ce régime
d'exception et là-dessus on on commence
à développer l'intercommunalité donc
euh je réserve évidemment mon vote sur
l'article parce que par contre sur
l'article je ne suis pas favorable à
l'article tel qu'il est rédigé
aujourd'hui et je pense qu'il faudrait
l'amender alors peut-être que le
gouvernement d'ailleurs avant que nous
ne votions sur l'amendement de
suppression pourrait se poser la
question de savoir si il peut pas
commencer enfin nous annoncer qu'il est
favorable à une clause du type de celle
que je viens d'énoncer qui est
généralisation de l'interco sans clause
de taille ça serait utile pour le vote
de de chacun me semble-t-il moi je sou
que le débat a lieu sur la façon de
faire l'intercoonite de France et après
nous viendrons sur la métropole on y
viendra différemment de ce qu' proposé
le gouvernement et de ce qu'a proposé la
Commission en tout cas de mon point de
vue
mais je suis pour le développement de
l'interco parce que je pense que c'est
nécessaire et qu'on comprendrait pas que
l'î- de France non ne s'y met pas ne se
met pas sur cette voie donc il faut
faire d'abord les intercs les faire
parler de l'article me paraît en tout
cas une bonne
chose chers collègues la parole est à
Monsieur Marseille pour explication de
vote
oui monsieur le Président madames les
ministres monsieur le
rapporteur naturellement je voterai
l'amendement de Roger carou dont je suis
cosignataire je pense effectivement que
il faut davantage de temps euh pour
pouvoir aller vers
l'intercommunalité voulu par le texte
pour une simple et bonne raison d'abord
parce que il y a beaucoup de procédures
j'ai euh comme l'a dit ma collègue
madame Debray tout à l'heure euh
l'honneur d'être le vice-président d'une
agglomération qui la seule dans les
hautes scènes avoir plus de 300000
habitants il nous a fallu des années
pour arriver à nous mettre d'accord
entre commune nous allons avoir des
élections municipales l'an prochain il
est possible que des équipes changent en
tous les cas elles vont être à tout le
moins modifié il y a des des procédures
très lourdes certaines de ces
collectivités dont la nôtre comprennent
des communes qui ne sont pas dans leur
département et donc qui complique qui
complexifi et qui alourdissent davantage
encore les procédures donc il faut
pouvoir se donner le temps pour
travailler voyez le srift on parle de la
facilité à décider ça fait 20 ans qu'il
est en cours d'élaboration le drift
d'Île-de-France c'est celui de 94 donc
c'est vous dire s'il faut du temps pour
que les procédures avancent et
aujourd'hui on nous dit on va faire un
schéma territorial
métropolitain si on veut construire du
logement ce qui est le but de la
manœuvre faut faire confiance aux élus
on peut pas imposer c'est pas les
fonctionnaires de la métropole ou les
préfets qui vont construire c'est les
maires qui vont construire et on est en
train de les déposséder du pouvoir c'est
celui de l'urbanisme il va leur rester
la fête des voisins et le mariage pour
tous je suis pas sûr qu'avec ça ils vont
produire beaucoup de logements
donc et ils vont être invités à faire un
tour en bateauouche chaque année avec le
président de la métropole je suis pas
sûr que ça soit très convainquant donc
il faut se donner les moyens de
travailler avec les élus locaux
c'est-à-dire ceux qui décident ceux qui
signent les permis et je vois
joyeusement ici des élus qui disent on
nous retire nos pouvoirs c'est bien
continuons et votons tout de suite
et moi je pense pas que on puisse
améliorer ces choses-là si on veut
avancer il faut le faire avec la
confiance et il faut le faire avec la
confiance des élus la conviction de ceux
qui agissent sur le terrain et tous ceux
qui sont qui sont ici sont des élus
locaux ils savent très bien que dans
leur communes dans leur collectivité on
avance et on construit parce qu'ils ont
la maîtrise de leur terrain ils
connaissent leur quartier ils savent où
on peut faire les choses et c'est pas en
déléguant le pouvoir et en applaudissant
joyeusement à la recentralisation qu'on
va pouvoir avancer donc je pense
effectivement qu'il y a tout lieu de de
supprimer ce texte de retravailler et
puis euh de faire confiance aux élus
locaux c'est la raison pour laquelle je
voterai cet amendement merci chers
collègues la parole est à Monsieur
carucci pour explication de vote
oui monsieur le Président Mesdames les
ministres mes chers collègues on a
entendu beaucoup de choses mais
sincèrement il y a une preuve en tout
cas c'est que beaucoup de choses sont
dites en contradiction avec simplement
l'autonomie la liberté des communes
voilà alors ça c'est le premier point si
si Monsieur kalaltenbach le deuxième
point c'est que vous dites vous-même il
y a des efforts qui sont faits il y a
des intercommunalités qui existent mais
vous reconnaissez vous-même que le
niveau de 200000 on sait pas bien qui y
arrivera et comment ça veut dire en
clair qu'on dit et moi je partage
l'opinion qui a étémise tout à l'heure
par Vincent capocanelas oui il faut
faire de l'intercommunalité en proche
cour mais il faut pas nous dire c'est
200000 c'est la base c'est le ticket
d'entrée parce que ça premier point ça
ne veut rien dire par rapport à ce qui
existe et qu'on va devoir casser pour
faire autre chose mais si on va devoir
le casser pour faire autre chose alors
comment voulez-vous que réagissent les
maires et les populations qu'on a
regroupé qui vont dire ah bah non nous
là il y a que 100000 ça va pas ah bah là
300000 finalement c'est idiot enleverz
en S pour le donner au voisins ça ça n'a
pas de sens de nous dire de faire ça
comme ça voilà donc ça c'est le premier
point sur l'intercommunalité oui en
petite couronne et je partage totalement
la vie de Philippe daller si vous pensez
que parce que on fait ça la péréquation
va être plus facile entre les
territoires difficiles et les
territoires favorisés c'est l'inverse
parce que vous allez démultiplier le
nombre d'acteurs décideurs donc
franchement sur ce plan ça n'a pas de
sens le deuxième élément je le dis au
sénateur café franchement oui c'est vrai
que dans cette région on se bat depuis
des années pour qu'on construisse plus
mais enfin c'est pas parce que vous
allez créer la métropole c'est pas parce
qu'il va y avoir des EPCI qu'on va
construire plus le problème de la
construction en Île-de-France sont les
terrains ce c'est le financement c'est
l'ensemble des sujets et là-dessus ça
fait 10 ans qu'on se bat pour trouver
des solutions et quel que soit le
gouvernement d'ailleurs les solutions
pour le moment on les a pas parce que
c'est très c'est très facile de nous
dire on va mettre à disposition les
terrains de les SNCF RTP et cetera c'est
beaucoup plus difficile de le faire et
par conséquent jusqu'ici on a un vrai
problème de terrain et ça moi je me suis
battu avec je dis avec pas contre le
président Huchon pour obtenir des
solutions et on s'est battu et on met en
région 250 millions d'euros alors que
c'est théoriquement pas de notre
compétence mais vous nous dites
maintenant ah ben tenez on vous fait une
métropole pour 10 millions d'habitants
sur les 12 millions et on lui donne le
logement et vous dites à la région et
vous on vous laisse les transports
sincèrement quelle politique c'est ça
non monsieur café monsieur café vous
défendez les intérêts de Paris c'est
bien mais regardez quand même aussi le
fait qu'entre les transports et le
logement il y a une corrélation il y a
une corrélation séparer la capacité la
compétence transport de la compétence
logement ça n'a pas de sens vous allez
construire quoi 70000 logements dans des
endroits et on dira ensuite ah bah à la
région au fait c'est vous qui avez la
compétence transport merci de venir
faire des lignes là où on a construit
alors que vous n'avez pas vous la
compétence logement enfin
et mais mais monsieur café moi je pense
que il y a deux solutions en vrai il y a
la solution d'alliier et il a la
solution la mienne région mais c'est
tout et vous avez choisi justement ni
l'une ni l'autre vous avez choisi celle
où il y a une strate supplémentaire une
complexification supplémentaire une
obligation pour les élus en EPCI et pas
de solution réel concerté fait de la
région ou de ce que propose Philippe la
métropole et regrouper logement
transport et l'essentiel c'est évident
que c'est ça c'est ou l'un ou l'autre et
vous avez choisi ni l'un ni l'autre pour
complexifier le système sincèrement
c'est
invivable ch madame la min j'ai encore
une demande de si vous le voulez bien
peut-être très bien la parole est à
Monsieur Dallier pour explication de
vote je serai très court monsieur le
Président Mad le ministre mais je
voudrais qu'il y ait unesens qu'on ne
fasse pas certains ont dit dans le débat
il y a le sujet de l'interco et puis il
y a le sujet de la métropole ayant l'air
de dire que ce sont des sujets dissociés
il y a pas plus faux que ça si parce que
quand on me dit après tout il faut faire
rentrer la région Île-de-France dans le
droit commun et cetera et donc bouclons
l'interc en petite couronne et pourquoi
pas avec les règles qui sont applicables
en province et ailleurs mais c'est bien
là le cœur du débat c'est qu'il ne faut
pas faire ça et si en 2010 on avait
différé c'était bien dans l'attente d'un
débat sur la métropole qu'est-ce qu'elle
doit être donc on ne peut pas dire c'est
un premier pas acceptons ça et ça nous
donne du temps parce que tous ceux qui
ont mis en place des interc ici le
savent bien il faut combien d'années
pour que ça deviennent un peu
opérationnel 3 ans 4 ans 5 ans et donc
dans vers la fin des années 2010 en
2018-29 on dira bah attendez maintenant
on va faire la métropole on est
tellement en retard qu'on ne peut pas
faire comme cela et voilà pourquoi il
faut aller vers le modèle lyonnais qui
aurait j'allais dire l'outrecuidance ici
déposer un amendement pour dire que bah
écoutez dans la métropole de Lyon
finalement on va conserver des
communautés de communes des communautés
d'agloot c'est l'antithèse c'est
l'antithèse donc effectivement il n a
effectivement il n'y a que deux
solutions la métropole intégrée sur un
périmètre serré et je redis ici que sur
8 % du territoire de la région
île-de-fance la petite couronne vous
avez 65 % de la population est-ce que ce
territoire ne mérite pas un modèle de
gouvernance particulier par rapport à la
grande couronne qui pourrait être
organisé différemment et après
réfléchissons effectivement à la manière
de faire coopérer le modèle de
gouvernance sur la zone danse la région
Île-de-France et ce que nous
organiserions sur la grande couronne
c'est cela qu'il faut faire et
n'opposons pas les uns aux autres ça n'a
pas de sens de dire qu'un outil de
gouvernance sur la zone dense
s'opposerait forcément à à la grande
couronne ou à la région ça n'a pas de
sens ou alors c'est le modèle régional
c'est voilà il y a pas il y a pas de
troisième solution or là vous voulez
nous faire un grand pas en avant en nous
proposant quelque chose qui n'est pas
une métropole et quand on en viendra à
discuter du logement et bien je pense
que je vous démontrerai assez aisément
que ce que vous allez nous proposer ça
ne réglera pas le problème du logement
sur le terrain alors de grâce ne faisons
pas ce que certains présentent comme une
mise à l'uniformité de la région
île-de-fance parce que c'est vraiment
pas la bonne solution merci chers
collègues la parole est à Monsieur ur
Dilain ensuite à Madame la Ministre
oui monsieur le Président Madam les
ministres moi je comprends tout à fait
la logique de Philippe daliier c'està
dire que il demande de supprimer euh
l'article 10 et et les autres d'ailleurs
parce qu'il a un un un un remplacement
une stratégie de remplacement qu'il a
exprimé depuis longtemps et d'ailleurs
j'ai presque envie de dire bah chich
monsieur kucci euh votez voter
l'amendement de Monsieur daller et puis
et puis les choses voilà seront faites
voilà donc en ce qui concerne par contre
Monsieur delay qui espère que dans 6
mois on aura on trouvera des solutions
enfin je vous trouve très optimiste et
tant mieux d'ailleurs mais com comment
voulez-vous enfin Jean-Pierre café l'a
dit mais comment voulez-vous quand 6
mois même en un an on trouve des
solutions cont tenu de ce qui s'est
passé moi j'ai assisté à toutes les
réunions j'étais à la première réunion
dans le bureau de Monsieur de laanoé et
jusqu'à ça a été créé à clichisouois
Paris Métropole la conférence fr
métropolitaine puis Paris Métropole j'ai
assisté à toutes les réunions jusqu'à
tant que je ne sois plus mare donc et
bien sûr qu'il faut rendre hommage aux
élus parce que c'est pas la faute des
élus si ça se passe comme ça c'est qu'on
est au cœur de nos contradictions comme
j'ai dit tout à l'heure l'autre jour
dans la direction dans la discussion
générale comment voulez-vous que ces
contradictions disparaissent comme par
enchantement alors qu'elles ont bloqué
le débat de la gouvernance pendant des
années c'est pas possible donc là il y a
il y a un sujet très important et il
faut le faire moi je propose que on on
discute on amende on améliore l'article
10 mais l'article 11 12 éventuellement
13 parce que je crois que Vincent capana
se trompe je pense que si on ne vote pas
l'article 10 j'ai du mal à imaginer
qu'on va examiner les articles qui
devraient par cohérence tomber à mon
sens mais je ne suis pas juriste donc
c'est le le choix est important donc
faisons-le et puis au moins on sortira
avec un texte qui pourra évoluer madame
la ministre l'a dit dans les deè lecture
mais mes chers collègues pensez pensez
quand même à ce que au symbolle que
représenterait pour nous les sénateurs
pour le Sénat tout entier que après un
texte Paris Métropole sorte pardon un
texte de métropole sorte du Sénat sans
un mot sur la métropole parisienne
pensez à
ça
non merci Monsieur rapporteur la parole
est à Madame la Ministre et la colère
des élus de de toute l'Île de
France vous verrez mais vous verrez vous
verrez je je sais pas merci Monsieur
monsieur le Président
ministre bien les monsieur kucci vous
dites au fond les reprenant l'argument
des 240 millions d'euros de contribution
de la région î-de-france au logement la
région Île-de-France enlève ses 240
millions d'euros enfin és pas la
réion mais il a voté les 240 millions
avec
enthousiasme non il a pas s bref je ne
reviens pas à
l'histoire pour pour le comprendu je
suis interrompu sur différents banques
ce qui fait
effectivement déstabiliser mon propos je
voulais juste vous dire qu'au fond vous
avez vous avez raison mais aujourd'hui
l'île-de- France n'a pas la compétence
logement on en est bien
d'accord donc donc vous vous
dites vous vous dites je donne la
compétence non mais on fait pas un
dialogue on n pas le droit mais je donne
la compétence logement à la région et
vous dites dans ces cas-là tous les élus
de toute l' de France vont t ravis
d'avoir perdu et tous les départements
vont être ravis d'avoir perdu la
compétence logement dans les interc
partout ils n'auront plus rien à dire
sur le logement c'est la région qui s'en
occupera honnêtement dans ce qu'on
propose il n'y a pas plus de raison de
que ce que vous proposez mais pour
répondre à à Monsieur Dallier si
effectivement vous rejetez l'article 10
ce qui est votre proposition je vois pas
comment après vous rentrez dans dans
dans le débat parce que même si vous
créer vos départements vous n'êtes pas
sûr de de l'emporter je dis entre les
deux lectures quelqu'un disait à
l'Assemblée nationale vous aurez une
majorité c'est aussi compliqué à
l'Assemblée Générale à l'Assemblée
pardon nationale qu'au Sénat sur cette
question et et c'est compliqué parce
qu'effectivement certains voudrai qu'on
aille très très vite d'autres
moins je pense quand même que et et vous
prenez la métropole marseillaise qui
elle peut-être je l'espère en tout cas a
une chance de se créer pourquoi elle a
une chance de se créer la métropole
marseillaise parce que on a des interc
qui fonctionnent déjà qu'on peut les
fusionner et donc elle a une chance en
tout cas c'est plus facile de créer
comme ça une fusion d'Interco d'avoir
deux niveaux euh que cette petite
couronne où c'est compliqué quand même
l'organisation intercommunale donc moi
je suis prête à entendre que le projet
de gouvernement n'était pas de qualité
euh suffisante pour provoquer
l'enthousiasme sur tous les bancs la
commission des lois déjà a fait remarque
sur les 300000 habitants par exemple
enant c'est beaucoup trop d'accord nous
euh ni Anne-Marie Escoffier ni moi n
allons nous acharner à garder les 300000
habitants euh pour niveau minimum des
des des interc on on est on entend le
travail des parlementaires euh quand
madame la présidente de la délégation
nous dit avec d'autres de ses collègues
il faut au moins cinq communes moi je
trouve que c'est raisonnable on peut
avancer vers une solution raisonnable
lâcher les 300000 habitants le
gouvernement n'en sera pas Marie mais
avancer vers quelque chose de de plus
simple prendre une raisonnablement aussi
le nombre des communes parce que c'est
vrai les intercomunutés de deux trois
communes il y en a quand même beaucoup
et elles ont montré malheureusement leur
limites on est capable nous en tout cas
et je m'y engage avec Anne-Marie
Escoffier qui j'ai pu échanger parce que
au niveau de de d'intensité des débats
nous le permettait on est capable de
lâcher sur ces deux points et d'accepter
quelque chose de différent de ce qui
était la la version de gouvernement
c'est le rôle du Parlement que de
l'enrichir en revanche ne plus avoir
d'article 10 et ne plus avoir
l'obligation des intercours en première
couronne monsieur garucci si vraiment ça
mettait en colère tous les élus de faire
ses intercs si vraiment c'était
insupportable pour les maires alors
pourquoi vous l'avez voté en décembre
2010 pour toutes les intercommunautés de
France mais votre famille politique
alors il faudrait dire au ban ma famille
politique a eu tort de faire un schéma
des intercommunités dans toute la France
et elle l'a fait donc ce que nous
voulons c'est que c'est égalité de droit
des intercour raisonnables et on entend
les propositions qui sont faites puis
après dans l'article 11 12 et cetera on
va continuer à
discuter merci madame la ministre je
n'ai plus de demande iation de vote j'ai
été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe UMP sur les
amendements je vous rappelle que l'avis
de la commission est défavorable lais du
Gouvernement est défavorable il va être
procédé au scrutin public dans les
conditions fixées par l'article 56 du
règlement le scrutin sera ouvert dans
quelques
instant
scrutin est
ouvert résultat du scrutin numéro
249 sur les amendements 23 rectifiéquat
230 rectifié et 447 à l'article 10
nombre de votants
347 nombre de suffrages exprimés
319 pour l'adoption 62 contre 157 le
Sénat a
adopté nous quittons l'hémicycle du
Sénat merci à vous d'avoir suivi cette
séance si vous souhaitez la revoir ou en
savoir plus sur la décentralisation
notre site internet publsenat.fr tout de
suite c'est le journal de 19h présenté
ce soir par Michel grossior bonne soirée
à
tous